bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle foire aux questions
sur un tract science x en question qui
sera aujourd'hui consacré à la datation
des fossiles et pour laquelle le
j'accueille aujourd'hui deux
spécialistes le docteur chantal tribolo
chargé de recherche au cnrs bonjour
bonjour et le docteur xavier boes chargé
d'opération et de recherche à l'inra
bonjour bonjour alors chantal vous êtes
géo geogreen l'axé ça ce que vous pouvez
nous parler un petit peu de votre
spécialité
donc je suis je ou chrono log au cnrs /
université de bordeaux bord de montaigne
et je travaille principalement sur la
chronologie du beatle stone age toute la
période entre 300 et 30 mille ans qui a
vu émerger les premiers haman adji amato
milk moderne et j'utilise principalement
une méthode dont on parlera tout à
l'heure qui s'appelle la méthode des
deux éliminés sans stimuler je suis
genre que l'on gagnera donc c'est tout
ce qui a trait à léo discipline ne
géologique appliquée à l'archéologie
donc en tant que chargé d'opération mais
je traite beaucoup des sujets en fait
d'aider des territoires qui sont en
rhône alpes
et puis pour toute la partie recherche
en fait c'est plutôt en afrique en
afrique de l'est sur un bassin lacustre
qui le bassin du turkana et là je
travaille sur des périodes très anciens
enfin un ancien pour la préhistoire
puisqu'on mais vers 3 4 millions
d'années et donc c'est tout ce qui a
trait aux disciplines de la
stratigraphie de la sédimentologie de la
géologie et bien sûr aussi la maîtrise
de tout ce qui est à ce psg ou
chronologique très bien donc deux grands
experts aujourd'hui pour répondre à nos
questions sur les datations on va se
baser sur un article récemment publié en
français et que c'est assez important
pour le préciser ce sera en français et
je vais le mettre du coup dans la
description afin que vous puissiez le
allez le lire parce que c'est un article
très intéressant et qui fait donc le
point sur les différentes méthodes de
datation et il ya une figure en
particulier qui je trouve résume assez
bien la façon dont les méthodes
utilisées et la façon dont on utilise
ces méthodes pour dater les fossiles en
tout cas pour les disons cinq derniers
millions d'années après les méthodes on
parlera rapidement des méthodes qui
permettent de dater les roches plus
ancienne que ça mais là où il ya une
vraie grosse diversité de méthode c'est
sur les cinq derniers millions d'années
donc on va suivre cette figure que je
vous présente en ce moment à l'image
donc commençons sans attendre par les
méthodes fondées sur la décroissance
radioactive donc ce qu'on appelle les
datation absolue si je me trompe pas
c'est ça oui
alors que toutes ces méthodes a donc
fondé sur de la décroissance radioactive
même d'une mais de manière générale
toutes les méthodes hit absolu ont
besoin d'un phénomène naturel qui va se
produire avec un temps que l'on sait que
l'on connaît qu'on va dire au cours l'on
peut déterminer et la radioactivité est
une horloge naturel très pratique donc
très utilisé en quoi ça consiste
il ya des atomes qui sont naturellement
instable ça veut dire qu'ils vont se
transformer en d'autres atomes ce qu'on
appelle la décroissance radioactive et
cette décroissance radioactive se fait
avec un rythme qui est propre à chaque
radio éléments par exemple pour le le
carbone 14 c'est environ 5700 30 ans
alors c'est la période c'est à dire
qu'en cinq mille sept cent trente ans la
moitié du crédit carbone qui était
présent initialement s'est transformée
et donc c'est selon c'est période qui
alors pour ceux suivant les règlements
peuvent être plus ou moins longue a
parfois six millions d'années qui vont
nous permettre d'aller plus ou moins
loin d'antan et ce qui va différencier
les différentes méthodes sur le poney
sur la décroissance radioactive c'est
aussi l'histoire qui va amener parce
qu'il nous faut un état initial que l'on
connaît c'est à dire soit 100% du radio
éléments présents et aucun de ses
descendants séparés ou contraire 0% d'un
fils qu'on va chercher à avoir croître
on peut peut-être commencer par le
radiocarbone du coup donc typiquement le
radiocarbone comment ça se passe c'est
le radiocarbone ils formés dans
l'atmosphère parce qu'il ya tous les
rayons cosmiques vous demandez proton
qui vont interagir avec la zot la halle
de notre atmosphère et plein gaz hotte
et ça va former le l'isotope qu'on
appelle le carbone 14 qui lui va être
incorporé au dioxyde de carbone qui
lui-même va être incorporé dans toutes
les plantes ont tout là tout le système
de la biosphère et il va se mettre en
équilibre en fait avec le bio carbone
atmosphérique donc en fait d'aller dans
les plantes dans les coraux dans tout ce
qui a ingéré du du carbone
naturellement on est dans les animaux
qui vous mangez les plantes
il va y avoir une certaine quantité de
radiocarbone mais à partir du moment où
l'organisme moeurs cet échange avec
l'atmosphère ne se fait plus et du coup
la quantité de carbone 14 qui est un
atom donc avec une décroissance comme je
disais tout à l'heure où 5700 de 30 ans
pour la période
cette quantité va décroître et donc ce
qu'on va regarder là c'est le rapport en
fait entre le carbone 14 et le carbone
total donc c'est le carbone 12 carbone
13 dont quoi mesurer les trois est
mesuré ce rapport si on est proche de
100 %
ça veut dire que
soit 100 % de la quantité de carbone
attendu par rapport aux rapports stander
ça veut dire que quand on a la quantité
de carbone qu'on s'attend à trouver chez
un être vivant
voilà le fossile est très jeune et si on
n'a presque plus de radiocarbone ce
rapport est très proche de zéro
d'assagir qu'il est très vieux donc en
fait eu sa voix en année sur cette
digression jouer nantes mais le problème
c'est que cette petite hypothèse que le
taux est toujours le maire dans
l'atmosphère c'est pas c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai ça a changé au cours du
temps parce que là les flux de rayons
cosmiques ont changé avec le soleil qui
s'est donc il faut pouvoir calibre et
donc il ya tout un travail de
calibration qui a été fait avec d'autres
méthodes de datation sur des coraux sur
des arbres etc pour pouvoir dire à telle
période le taux qu'on attend le taux
initial il est de temps il ya aussi
autre chose c'est que tout ça est
valable si l'organisme n'a pas absorbé
du carbone anciens il ya ce problème
aussi qui est donc l'effet réservoir
donc si par un organisme qui se va être
un fossile qui va être datés ci a le
risque qu'il a pu assimiler du dans sa
vie du carbone plus anciens je prends un
exemple tout bête par exemple moi qui ai
travaillé dans dans la zone chilienne il
ya des volcans s'est posé le problème
que parfois lors d'explosions audio
volcanique il ya d une libération de
carbone ça ça peut drôlement biaisé
voilà le l'échantillon dalle est donc
adapté donc ça c'est très important de
calibrer comme tu disais par d'autres
méthodes indépendants qui n'ont pas ce
problème de l'effet réservoir il ya là
calibre est le propre de la calibration
d'une manière générale avec ce taux en
fait initial qui a varié au cours du
temps il ya tout un tas de
alors j'avais noté les faits réservoir
l'effet vieux bois les faits pose bon me
l'effet révolution industrielle etc qui
font que le il ya des désaccords
foration mon parasites de carbone qui
est qui qui font que base ça se passe
pas tout à fait comme encore comme on
voudrait pour que ce soit simple en fait
donc le garden les petites complexité
supplémentaire d'accord donc le oui la
datation radio chronologique quand on
utilise le carbone 14 donc se base sur
le principe que normalement tout animal
enfin tout être vivant à la même
quantité de carbone au moment où il
meurt et qu'après cette quantité va
diminuer parce qu'il n'a corp aurait pu
de nouveau carbone mais mais mais il ya
des effets confondant il ya des noms
mais ça on en est tout à fait conscient
c'est à dire qu'on est capable de
corriger pour ses effets on est où
oui on est capable c'est pas surface et
alors il ya aussi une chose importante
c'est qu'il faut travailler sur la
qualité de l'échantillon et s'apparente
si le risque quand on envoie une date
and un objet à dater enfin un
échantillon à dater un adapteur il faut
vraiment qu'ils aient un bagage très
très comment dire complet autour de cet
échantillon pour que le d'atr il est
vraiment tout en un pour savoir ce qui
date parce qu'en fait on peut dater
n'importe quoi c'est à dire que l'on
peut obtenir 1 h sur n'importe quoi donc
c'est il ya vraiment l'importance de
travailler sur la qualité des chants
pardon j'ai adapté rond mais quand on
dit n'importe quoi n'importe quoi de
biologique
mais pour lui car dan 14 c'est à dire il
faut juste pour préciser pour les
auditeurs ils n'auraient pas encore
conscience mais le carbone 14 a
évidemment vu que c'est du carbone on
s'attend à le trouver chez des
organismes pas à n'importe où organic
bouacha et je rajoute quand même que ce
que j'en ai pas parlé
la dernière fois que maintenant on date
les métaux fer avec cette méthode
il ya une spécialiste sud a pu mat qui
s'appelle stéphanie leroy qui travaille
dans mon ex futur labo ou futurs ex
labos qui dit
développer cette méthode parce qu'en
fait les métaux étaient fendues avec du
charbon de bois du charbon de bois
ferait d'ailleurs et les particules
explique exactement commandes de ce
charbon se retrouve en fait dans la dans
l'alliage et en allant chercher ses
petites particules mais on peut dater le
métal mais c'est bon c'est un espace
très peu quatre entités oui oui le
fameux char banque le fallait fermer
carbone qui rend l'acier très cassant
parce qu'on n'aime pas voir les âmes les
amateurs de médiévistes mme
reconnaîtront cette affirmation qui en
disait donc la sélection du canadien je
prends un exemple très simple quand je
disais on peut dater n'importe quoi je
prends un exemple très simple des
charbons de bois dans un sol on va on
n'a pas de quantités suffisantes de
carbone a envoyé au laboratoire pour que
soit donnée donc on va prendre un risque
on a deux options on va prendre les
chardons qui sont dans le sol et on va
mélanger ces charbon pour en faire une
quantité suffisante a envoyé au
laboratoire et voilà c'est ça le
laboratoire donnant une date
le problème c'est si derrière on n'a pas
su que c'était en fait un assemblage de
charbon de plein de sources de pieux
différents d'âge différents qui sont
dans le sol eh bien on va obtenir une
date moyenne d'un ensemble de date
voilà ça c'est très important donc c'est
pour ça qu'il vaudrait mieux accorder
plus d'importance à la qualité
d'échantillons et aussi à savoir ce qu
date précisément c'est pour ça que des
foires souvent s'intéresse plus à des
micros datation sur des micro des
échantillons pour faire de la m s qui
exige moins de quantité pour un autre
exemple par exemple on peut faire une
datation sur le l'organique de total or
ce qu'on appelle en anglais au total
organique carbone à tout le carbone
totale d'un celi mans par exemple
sauf que par exemple en travaillant sur
des sédiments lacustres on s'est rendu
compte que c'était trop dangereux de
faire ce type de natation parce que même
si on prend une très petite quantité de
sédiments qu'on se met à dater on peut
avoir un assemblage très complexe de
différentes sources de carbone dans un
celi mans et qui va donner un âge qui
sera très loin d'eux
de ce qui devrait être en fait en
réalité
donc en fait qu'on peut faire c'est
vraiment extraire présente dans le que
dans cet exemple d'un sédiments
lacustres
plutôt que de faire un échantillon très
gros avec le risque d'avoir plusieurs
sources de carbone on va plutôt faire
des extractions de plans de micro
organismes pour faire simplement une
datation sur cet objet là plutôt que de
faire un assemblage très risqué il ya
toutes les contaminations aussi qu'ils
sont qui peuvent être un problème je
suppose
rien que de fait de toucher un
échantillon par exempe avec les doigts
faut éviter un c'est sûr quand même avec
les systèmes d'ultrafiltration tout ça
il arrive à pas mal nettoyé mais voilà
après ceux ci c c'est à dire c'est pas
juste pour terminer là dessus c'est à
dire n'importe qui peut envoyer un ex un
échantillon de charbon ou de carbone et
de tissus à laboratoire et obtenir une
date mais ça veut pas dire que cette
date sera correct et ben oui c'est clair
que là il faut vraiment un fan sera
correct du point de vue méthodes de
datation mais après il faut vraiment
s'attacher bas aux autres méthodes aux
autres disciplines que par exemple la
stratigraphie la sédimentologie l'étude
des sols
voilà faut vraiment travailler beaucoup
de gens ou avoir des compétences
associées à la date parce que ya le
risque d'obtenir une date
oui mais encore ici beaucoup plus
intéressant est fiable et comme on dit
robuste d'avoir vraiment autour de
l'échantillon à dater une séparant
préféré date et une séquence
stratigraphie très bien très bien
préservé avec une bonne rythmicité des
dépôts plutôt que deux dates et des
dépôts qui sont moins bien qu'ils ont
été conçus de l'érosion par exemple donc
là c'est plus risqué parce qu'il y aura
le problème de rodez plein de choses
différentes et de d'abord une date qui
est qui n'est pas représentatif de l'âge
du sédiment par exemple lorsque ça va
être un thème récurrent pendant cette
interview que il n'ya pas une méthode de
datation magique c'est à dire que
obtenir une date carbone 14
ça suffit ma faut avoir plein de dates
qui viennent de plein de niveaux
différents et d'autres méthodes aussi
pour pouvoir faire des recoupements
en fait il faut travailler
le mieux c'est de comparer avec d'autres
méthodes de datation ok ok donc voilà
message à tous les auditeurs vous pouvez
faire date et n'importe quoi au carbone
14 mai pas mais vous pouvez pas faire
n'importe comment
c'est à dire que ça ça demande quand
même une certaine rigueur dans la
collecte du matériel hockey et du coup
question question qui revient très
souvent dates et les dinosaures ça
donnerait quoi si je vous donne un os de
dinosaures forcément en hausse et
qu'importe si c'est possible parce qu'on
avait classé 14e ne remonte que jusqu'à
5 en gros 1 50 million ways
alors bon mais qu'est ce qu'on s'attend
à trouver du coup si je vous donne un
fossile qui à 70 millions d'années
qu'est-ce qu'on s'attend à trouver cette
salade l'âge de faire tourner avec en
dehors de la limite
oui ou alors s'il ya le risque d'avoir
du carbone
voilà c'est une pollution dans l'eau
fossile on va date et simplement la
pollution la pollution récente du
fossile d'accord d'accord d'accord très
intéressant comme comme réponse merci a
donc une datation
si on obtient un âge de cinq mille ans
sur un os un fossile de dinosaure
s'avouera pas dire qu'ils datent de 5000
ans donc la personne pourra être
convaincu qu'il a cinq mille ans mais
non ce n'est pas possible parce qu'il ya
d'autres méthodes justement qui montrent
que ce n'est pas possible
outre le fait que vous pensez qu'ils
n'auront pas ils sont beaucoup plus
vieux que ce grand nord et chantal vous
alliez dire quelque chose avant que je
vous interromps grossièrement
je pense que c'était au sujet du fait
qu' on cherche à adapter des
échantillons de plus en plus petits pour
contrôler justement tout ce qui est
problèmes de pollution problème
d'histoires différentes avec des
échantillons qui sont en fait des
composites d'échantillons et ça c'est on
ne retrouve dans presque toutes les
méthodes en fait en guinée sens on est
passé depuis maintenant vingt ans à de
la mesure monogramme on n'était pas
rigoureux et plus et l'aumône aux grains
une pêche pareil on essaye maintenant de
faire des transepts pourvoir dans les
parties différentes parties des
échantillons si les incorporations
d'uranium et tout ça se sont passés la
même façon donc c'est hong kong 10
miniaturise voit la synchro échantillons
rice et du micro échantillonnage jeu
plus en plus pour pouvoir avoir un
contrôle de ce qu'ont fait d'accord et
juste pour avoir une idée donc le
carbone 14 enfin la méthode de datation
au carbone 14 sa date des années 50 si
je me trompe pas puisque l'homme de
piltdown c'était à peu près une des
premières si je ne trompe pas
de combien combien il fallait au début
dans les années 50 de carbone pour il a
refait une datation
si elle parvient maintenant à bay avait
pas les ams donc la ms et les clients
d'une tête d'épinglé
avant il fallait plusieurs en quelques
grains voilà ces quelques grammes
je ne serai pas dire exactement combien
ce faire une représentation bad séjour
c'est un morceau de sucre ou voilà le
charbon déjà groupe quoi d'accord
l'équivalent c'était vraiment très
destructif
on faisait du comptage bêta cédé contre
eux on comptait le nombre de
désintégrations en regardant les bêta
qui sont émis à chaque fois qu'il ya
carbone 14 qui se désintègre là
maintenant on compte le nombre d'atomes
qui reste c'est des méthodes qui sont
complètement différentes et d'ailleurs
dont l'une étant beaucoup plus sensible
que l'autre les âges sont exprimés en
bis est en fait bip y ont donc pour le
radiocarbone cbi ford présent et le
présent pour eux c'est 1950 d'accord
alors qu'on sent qu'ils ont inventé et
par convention aussi on utilise toujours
quand les algues sont présentes en libye
en fait il ya la période que l'on
pensait connaître en 1950 donc alors
maintenant donc on a gardé cette période
qui est légèrement différente de la
vraie période donc quand un échantillon
après il est calibré d'après corrige par
la vraie période
oui parce que voilà il ya le problème
des calibrations parce que d'un dans le
temps il ya eu il ya des intervalles de
temps qu'ils sont moins bien datable
parce qu'il ya des plateaux voilà ça
c'est encore autre chose mais donc il ya
besoin d'autres méthodes qui ne
subissent pas ses effets comme par
exemple la dent on en viendra ou viendra
après j'aurai je le sais mais elle part
donc la dendrochronologie qui permet de
calibrer ces intervalles de temps parce
qu'ils ne subissent pas eu le même effet
y est vous avez évoqué l'existence de
plateau qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors
les plateaux c'est en fait dans le temps
quand on regarde les courbes de
calibration
il ya un moment où ça va ça va être tout
plat c'est à dire que quand on a notre
mesure de carbone 14 actuelle ça va nous
deux
et une grande plage de temps au lieu de
nous donner juste un point sur une
courbe voilà qu'il s'est plu c'est plus
une espèce de fonctionnaires ça peut
faire un plateau comme ça donc
et c'est par exemple je crois le cas
pour période de l'âge du fer web apps à
savoir sur 500 ans alors que le carbone
14 ont toutes ces personnes que d'être
plus précis mais on va pas savoir si
c'est au début de sa période de cinq
cents ans ou plus tôt à la fin voilà je
sais pas si je suis suffisamment ces
cinq-là et du coup comment on corrige ça
comment on arrive à ben alors faire
appel à d'autres méthodes oui voilà
c'est un peu la donne mais tempère près
il ya des courbes de calibration qui
sont régulièrement mises à jour avec il
ya des petits programmes comme accent
que c'est accessible eux mêmes en libre
accès souvent c'est oxford un lien
oakscan oui mais enfin mais l'a laissé
la cour de cass
c'est en comparant avec d'autres
méthodes par exemple je prends le cas de
parents dans la sédimentation la cus il
ya eu beaucoup de travaux fait parvenir
carré d'as dans les lacs suisses par
exemple où il ya eu justement des
prélèvements faits dans les lacs de
sédiments ou deux organismes à dater et
en parallèle il ya eu des datations sur
les barbes alors c'est très rare que les
vrais voir avec six dans le milieu la
cus mais quand ça et les listes c'était
un vrai sédimentation annuel c'est ça
que ça veut dire les bars on y viendra
après je le sais mais là du coup il ya
eu possibilité de mettre en parallèle
ces deux chronologie et donc ça ça a
servi à calibrer le sécateur il ya la
même démarche qui est fait un peu aussi
dans le bassin du quart yacco le caribou
bassin en anglais qui dans le golfe du
mexique
il ya eu les travaux de conrad le guen
dans les années 90 mais qui se
poursuivent encore maintenant où c'est
très rare d'avoir dans les océans d'eva
mais ça existe et en fait l'ac a permis
aussi de d'affiner les datations
obtenue avec le c 14 mais encore une
fois c'est très rare dans dans les
environnements sédimentaires d'avoir une
vraie sédimentation a rythmé
annuellement
la plupart du temps on a le risque
d'avoir des intervalles qui sont
annuelles mais pas sur une chronologie
longue de plusieurs milliers d'années
c'est très très rare
on s'en rend pas compte finalement mais
daté au carbone 14 c'est quand même
hyper multidisciplinaire c'est à dire
que ça fait ça fait vraiment venir des
connaissances de partout quoi si on veut
obtenir des très bons des résultats
fiables où il est robuste et une affaire
de spécialistes
c'est un métier mais aussi sa franchise
pas la multiplication en fait des
travaux de datation parce que quand on a
à se lâche sur un objet à dater ou voilà
l'échantillon on va multiplier les
échantillons multiplient pas c'est ça
qui va être aussi intéressant un autre
chose qui sera intéressante à faire qui
est intéressante à faire c'est souvent
de confronter différents résultats
obtenus par différents laboratoires ça
s'appelait aussi intéressant parce qu'il
n'utilise pas forcément les mêmes
protocoles c'était surtout intéressant à
voir la ms maintenant je pense qu'avec
les méthodes d'al msc - un bébé mais je
crois savoir que les communautés de
radiocarbone east sais pas si c'est le
nom qu'on leur a donné ce jour d un
terreau comparaison de la soirée
régulière pour voir justement si sur un
même échantillon ne peuvent trouver
douceur une même tâche donc c'est d'un à
bois l'autre technique de préparation
sera l'atout de la mise au point de
l'appareil
enfin comme c'est complexe je repensais
en fait à la par rapport à ça c'est vrai
qu'il ya aucune méthode en fait qui est
parfaite quand on dit chronologie enfin
datation absolue c'est un peu un termes
abusifs je pense parce que en fait ça
donne l'impression que cet absolu mais
l'absence de doute en sciences n'existe
pas et il ya vraiment un besoin d'eux
de confronter les résultats avec
d'autres disciplines d'autres expertises
et aussi voir que chaque méthode en fait
à s'y limite pas quand on pense que on
peut calibrer le cap horn 14 avec par
exemple la dendre au chronologie les
cernes d'arbres
ces robustes effectivement puisque
chaque année un arbre va faire informer
une scène et puis donc effectivement
quand on a des collections de troncs
d'arbres qui ont plusieurs millions
milliers d'années et qu'on les met bout
à bout on va pouvoir comme ça avoir une
chronologie et asseoir la chronologie du
comparer avec la chronologie différents
bonne humeur du carbone 14 mai par
exemple les var ça c'est un domaine que
je maîtrise un peu plus moi je connais
les limites des vars et comme je le
disais c'est très très compliqué
complexe de vraiment prouvé qu une
sédimentation et annuel sur un laps de
temps qui est très long c'est à dire que
vraiment prouver que l'on a fait on se
sert du des vars dans les leurs que je
suis par exemple pour calibrer le
carbone 14
mais voilà il faut quand même avoir
derrière une vraiment une analyse très
lourde de la séquence stratigraphique
variés et du processus derrière qui
expliquent le lan une alimentation
annuel
donc moralité mais méfions nous des gens
qui disent qu'ils font de grosses
affirmations sur une soldate wii ou qui
disent que leur méthode de datation est
la meilleure par exemple oui oui bon
d'accord d'accord très bien et donc avec
le carbone 14 ans couvre les derniers 50
mille ans et ça on doit les deux
périodes
esker est au bout de cinquante mille ans
il me reste est tellement peu qu'on est
plus capable de le mesurer plus de
signal quoi donc il faut d'autres
méthodes pour prendre le relais d'accord
mais ses autres méthodes
elle fonctionne tout sur exactement le
même principe c'est juste que l'on
change les isotopes en fait on utilise
un autre at home quoi voilà on va
utiliser un autre à thomas lors du coup
elle est la mise en place de l'histoire
qui va faire qu'il faut un état
particulier au début pour qu'on puisse
se mesurer quelque chose puisqu'il la
décroissance elle va partir à partir
d'un certain état il faut connaître cet
état est donc l'histoire de
l'échantillon qui va faire qu'on arrive
dans cet état va être différente selon
qu'on va regarder là où l ut h où tous
les costauds génique donc ces voix là
c'est pas les mêmes matériaux loi c'est
pas tous sur les mêmes tâches c'est quoi
histoire l'ugtg uranium thorium d'accord
uranium thorium ouais d'accord et ça va
être aussi sur des matériaux différents
c'est à dire que le carbone 14 à ce gros
avantage de pouvoir dater les fossiles
directement par contre sur les autres
méthodes
ça va être il va falloir encadrer le
fossile entre exactement entre deux
dates quoi donc
alors on peut passer à l'uranium dormant
de plus un détail uranium thorium lui il
va on va l'appliquer surtout sur les
carbonates soit d'origine
minérale s'est alors c'est tout ce qui
espérait au thème nos questions les
stalags nique des planchers stalag
mythique et ou alors les carbonates
d'origine animale donc les coraux les
coquilles et puis le mali dans tard et c
est en fait dans la petite histoire que
je disais qui fait qu'on arrive à un
certain état c'est que dans l'eau il ya
de l'uranium ya pas de thorium ce que le
thorium est beaucoup moins insoluble il
va avoir tendance à précipiter tout de
suite et donc quand l'eau circule et
forme le cristal de carbonate balade eu
lieu dans le cristallier du coup de
l'uranium n'y a pas de thorium
normalement et donc on peut partir de
cet état où on a
tout notre uranium à leur donne cas du
l'uranium doria montbard garder
l'uranium 234 qui va se transformer en
thorium 230 et donc pas de torts m 230
au départ mais plein de d'uranium 234
est-ce qu'on va regarder justement c'est
au fil du temps comment le thorium 230
se remet avec libre avec l'uranium 234
donc remet à léquilibre ça veut dire
quoi c'est parce que dans une chaîne
radio active chaque je disais tout à
l'heure à chaque un radio élément à sa
sauce sa propre vitesse pour se
transformer et dans l'uranium en fait il
ya une dizaine d'éléments qui vont se
suivre comme ça mais chaque radio
éléments à sa propre son propre rythme
et donc alors noté un théorème de 130 75
mille cinq cent quatre-vingts ans voilà
où se transformer alors que l'uranium
234 période ses 245 milan bon voila et
est donc on va regarder
normalement dans une chaîne et dit à
léquilibre quand toutes les activités
c'est à dire le nombre de désintégration
par seconde sont les mêmes et en fait
quand on attend suffisamment longtemps
sur une chaîne qu'elle est bien dans un
milieu assez fermé on va avoir cet
équilibre qui va se créer au fil du
temps et donc là c'est ce que je disais
on a on cherche enfin le thorium 232 va
se remettre à l' équilibre avec
l'uranium 234 au cours du temps et ça va
prendre à peu près 500 milles 1 mille
cinq cent mille ans du coup ben on peut
plus ont peuplé la télé ça s'utilise sur
cinq cent mille ans donc à peu près oui
et si on veut remonter plus loin du coup
il ya je vois le potassium argon par
exemple voilà alors le potassium argon
alors qui peut dater aussi plus plus
jeunes ont mis et le potez marolles a
par contre on n'est plus du tout de même
type d'environnement le
le potassium argon la petite histoire un
truc qui fait qu'on peut utiliser cette
méthode c'est que quand les minéraux
dans les sédiments volcaniques se
cristallisent ils ont du potassium
mais tous leurs gonds qui d un
descendant du potassium 8 c'est un gaz
et du coup il va être évaporé au 10 mai
donc le cristal au début pas il est fort
mais il n'a que le potassium et dont le
potassium 40 qui inquiète radioactifs et
donc au fil du temps il va former de
l'arbre aux quarante
voilà peut-être même 40 avant 40 et avec
alors à une période là pour le coup est
très longue mais ce n'est pas gênant au
contraire ça permet de remonter beaucoup
plus loin dans le temps et donc on va
regarder les rapports entre alors le
larmont et le potassium où il ya des
techniques aussi ce qu'est ce qui est
gênant c'est que ces cristaux et peuvent
avoir par exemple quand ils se sont
formés prix et une bulle d'air dans
lequel il ya de l'argon atmosphérique et
donc piège piège l'équation on regarde
si on mesure cet arbre post eric balet
la gv être faut donc toutes les
techniques qui ont été développées
notamment avec la technique de l'argonne
transport une partie du potez sur 39 ans
narbonne 39 et du coup bas faire
évaporer les deux types dargaud en même
temps pour voir si c'est du vrai argon
initiale ou si ces mélanges aig de l'art
book ça par exemple pour prendre un cas
concret c'est ce qu'on utilise pour
dater les cendres volcaniques dans le
rift africain où il ya énormément de
retombées volcaniques qui on utilise
balle a rebondi pour dater lémanique
entre ces couches volcanique il ya les
fossiles d'hominidés de est en fait et
voilà en fait tous les fossiles connus
de nos mille idées où dominent
en fait sont datés par le biais de ces
techniques puisque il n'ya
principalement que deux techniques
utilisées dans le rift est africain et
plus particulièrement dans le bassin du
cur cas là c'est la méthode dite absolue
de l'aragon pour dater donc les les
retombées volcanique et il y en a
beaucoup c'est vrai que dans la zone
dans le bassin du pana une vingtaine sur
entre 4 millions d'années et amine
d'année et sinon le l'autre méthode
c'est une méthode plus relatif qui est
le palais le magnétisme c'est la
stratigraphie magnétique dont je crois
qu'on a pas d'accord donc l'an passé ces
fossiles d'hominidés là c'est pas eux
mêmes condate c'est finalement on trouve
le fossile et il est entre deux couches
voilà mais ces couches par contre on
arrive à les dates et donc on comptera
un agent fait votre à nager voilà il
faut trop le l'idéal c'est de trouver un
faux le fossile faut qu'ils soient
trouvées pas très loin quand même je
parle en termes de dispenses
stratigraphique d'un dut de retomber
mécanique qu'on appelle également des
puces volcaniques
parce que voilà le risque c'est que plus
on va être éloigné stratigraphique man
ou le col et les retombées balkany sont
espacés bon plus il va falloir
développer des modèles d'âge en fait
basée sur d'autres comme par exemple les
taux de sédimentation vol plutôt le mot
les modes de dépôt les modes dans les
environnements de dépôt d'accord et donc
avec ça avec ce potassium arbres montent
jusqu'à combien de millions d'années à
peu près ggn spécialistes dont j'ai
regardé ce que je voyais dans la
littérature et ça remonte jusqu'à
quelques milliards quand même ça fait
loin voilà mais bon ces deux techniques
ils sont assez précise et haut et on
peut adapter à ces jeunes aussi j'ai vu
je prends une application vous avez
essayé d'adapter l'éruption beaucoup
d'autres connais bien ajout du du vésuve
la poupée lit alors il avait 79 plus ou
moins 100 ce qui est pas très précis
mais bon ça montre etc
mais à l'échelle de millions d'années
c'est quand même une marge d'erreur que
quelques packs qui est pas honteuse
on va dire d'accord web après ça c'est
vrai qu'après toute façon quand il
s'agit de tâter des roches plus ancienne
que que quelques que quelques millions
d'années on va toujours utilisé plus ou
moins les mêmes méthodes donc c'est un
oui le potassium argon largo argon on va
utiliser les ir qu'ont beaucoup parce
que le là on va regarder en fait le ski
va nous intéresser c'est là la console
de désintégration de l'uranium 238 qui
est très grande
4,5 milliards d'années
donc ça va nous permettre vraiment de
date et des trucs très très danoise
installée il s'applique notamment voilà
ou rachat avec les dire qu'on les mots
nazis mais voilà un petit pic passer des
méthodes qu'on utilise pour des périodes
à 100 millions d'années 200 millions
d'années mais bon quand on fait des
tests nous on a fait des tests sur des
environnements sédimentaires carbonatées
à 3 millions de prises est bon il y
avait deux plombs ça ça ne marchait pas
voilà et donc là c'est l'ours et la
formation des minéraux alors je ne sais
plus exactement
enfin on estime que yahvé du de
l'uranium 238 au départ et pas son
descendant de tout au bout de la chaîne
qui ait du plomb 210 essais le rapport
le plomb 210 et l'uranium 238 qui va
être examinée et on va regarder aussi
pas se tromper l'uranium 235 et c'est
avec les produits stables je dis une
bêtise 2217 206 et 207 et donc on va
croiser ces différentes ses différentes
chaînes pour trouver pour trouver l'âge
mais le problème c'est que en fait il
peut y avoir du plomb initialement qui
n'est pas à lié à la décroissance est
toujours le petit piège qui fait que
l'hypothèse de départ et n'est pas tout
à fait juste et qu'il faut trouver des
chemins pour pour contourner ce piège
bon voilà ce que c'est on utilise
beaucoup le
on utilise beaucoup les ir condom qui
contiennent justement c'est ces éléments
radioactifs l'a donc sa part du principe
si je ne m'abuse que les zircon son sont
des cristaux très dur et donc la
quantité d'uranium qui emprisonne au
départ normalement reste inaltérée donc
toutes formes d'altération sera due à la
désintégration et mais par contre c'est
vrai que ça arrive des fois qu'on trouve
des dates un peu pété en tout cas quand
on compare à la stratigraphie encore une
fois une roche déposé sur une autre ne
peut pas être plus vieille que la roche
qui est en dessous sais c'est pas comme
ça que la gravité fonctionne donc si on
trouve une date plus jeunes sur un sur
une roche qui est censé être plus basse
on sait que la date et fosses donc est
ce encore une fois plus on remonte dans
le temps - on a deux techniques de
datation du coup plus il faut recouper
avec d'autres informations
elle est là en fait dans le la méthode
du pbc de regrouper différentes chaînes
justement nous dit pas ce que je disais
tout à l'heure
uranium 235 uranium 238 voilà oui mais
ces deux voilà fouquet pour chacun on
peut si je veux dire simplement calculer
un rapport et puis il faut que les deux
rapports concorde pour que là je sois
bon en gros et par rapport aux y
recourent l'atout talent jean tendu
effectivement ça c'est un élément dhabi
qui est bien choisi puisque c'est un
élément très stable de qui - à 20 qui
est pas une altéra mais qui résiste
fortement à l'altération cours du temps
donc il n'est pas choisie de façon en
ligne cet élément est donc la roche la
plus vieille sur terre a été daté grâce
aux ir content si je ne m'abuse donc la
date de 4 5 milliards d'années elle
vient justement des datations grâce aux
ir qu'on est en fait c'est pas la roche
qui elle même ancienne c'est le zircon
c'est à dire que le zircon a été
remaniée d'une roche qui est elle-même
plus ancien c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut dont il faut faire très très
attention si je ne m'abuse avec les ir
con parce que justement vu qu'ils sont
très solides
ça arrive très souvent qu'ils se forment
qu il soit érodée qu'il se re dépose et
que cette du coup la roche dans laquelle
on les trouve en fait
les y recourent à l'intérieur on nous a
dit que l'âge de la roche original donc
passé mais bon c'est des choses
auxquelles il faut faire attention et on
en est bien conscient quoi avec de
discipliner pour un match et on en
revient avec la qualité de l'échantillon
en fait il faut savoir vraiment bien
qu'elle en chine et on date et savoir le
contexte en fait c'est tout ce qui est
les notions du contexte
voilà après c'est vrai que les
laboratoires n'importe quel type d'avoir
un laboratoire quand on peut envoyer un
échantillon à dater il faut remplir une
fiche mais ça ça ça ne suffit pas il
faut vraiment que derrière il y ait un
ensemble de spécialistes et d'experts
qui se soient réunis sur le terrain à
l'endroit où le champion a été prélevé
pour avoir des informations beaucoup
plus complète quoi d'accord et bien si
je crois qu'on a bien fait le tour déjà
delà des méthodes fondées décroissance
radioactive
donc on peut commencer maintenant les
méthodes fondées sur les dommages causés
par la radioactivité donc on reste dans
la radioactivité et on reste alors
est-ce qu'on peut les qualifier de
datation absolue
ces méthodes a lui même dans la mesure
oui c'est vrai de chips ehpad et dans la
mesure par rapport à une datation
relative voilà c'est plus absolus que
relatifs donnent un âge d'accord avec
une certaine alors avec une précision
qui est beaucoup moins bonnes que pour
les méthodes qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent
la luminescence stimuler on est à 5% la
halle elektron spin résonance on va
plutôt être 10 15%
le lettrage officiant je ne sais plus
samedi pour ça aussi enfin bon c'est un
échelon supérieur quand même c'est ce
qui donne les fameuses barres d'erreur
koala alors je pense qu'on peut regarder
de plus les tresses de façon je vais
enfin je les rapprocherait quand même
plus de des méthodes précédentes
notamment d'autres ce qu'on a vu sur
l'uranium plan parce que là on va
regarder aussi ce qui se passe au niveau
de l'uranium 238 mais on va pas content
en fait elles rapports isotopiques on va
regarder ce qui se passe quand l'uranium
fils yonne parce qu'il ya différents
types de façon de pour l'uranium de
décroître de se transformer dans ses
descendants et un de ces types de
décroissance radioactive c'est la
fission peut dire que en fait le
l'uranium qui en gros ça tourne bien
bien lourd il va se scinder en deux et
en fin le le fait que la fille science
ça va faire un petit un petit recul
comme ça des des deux morceaux date au
pas des deux atomes qui sont formés et
ce petit recul va créer en fait un des
impôts va dire à défaut au sein du
cristal où ils se trouvent et et ce
défaut on peut la grandir avec un petit
traitement chimique et du coup on le
voit au microscope
donc ce qu'on va faire en fait c'est
qu'on va coûter on appelle ça des traces
on va compter le nombre de traces pour
dire quelle est la quantité en fait
d'uranium qui aficio nez depuis la
formation de la roche donc en fait c'est
beau considérer que c'est une autre
façon de voir la décroissance
radioactive
chantal vous êtes spécialiste de la
luminescence ça voilà alors moi
j'utilise la luminescence donc là on est
dans un autre registre parce que
l'hypothèse de base change en fait là on
a regardé les décroissance des chaînes
radioactives et on veut voir des
rapports ou voir comment on vous voir
quelque chose qui évolue dans le temps
sur le nombre de deux atomes ou sur la
désintégration qui s'est produite
ça change dans le temps alors que la sur
la luminescence on va aussi utiliser la
radioactivité naturelle issue du
l'uranium 238 du potassium 40 et du
thorium 232 quand on veut partout on a
aussi les rayonnements cosmiques qui
nous oppose en permanence mais là on va
considérer
que seychelles elles sont à l' équilibre
dans les sédiments ce qui est presque
vrai la plupart du temps et que donc la
radioactivité le taux de radioactivité
n'a pas changé et est donc l'énergie qui
a été libéré année après année du fait
de ces décroissance radioactive parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'une décroissance
radioactive yen il ya des particules qui
sont émises et elles sont porteuses
énergie et donc on va considérer que
cette énergique libéré a été constante
au cours du temps alors c'est parce
qu'aussi on travaille pas sur des
milliards d'années à l'échelle presque
de la période de ces différents radio et
noah mais sur des temps qui sont de
quelques centaines de milliers d'années
donc on peut considérer en première
approximation que ces quantités
d'énergie ont été constantes et donc
nous qui va nous intéresser c'est de
regarder quelle a été la quantité
d'énergie absorbée par des minéraux qui
sont dans les sédiments donc les crânes
quartz et les crânes feldspath en
général ça peut être des grains dans des
roches aussi on dater silex et ses dates
et céramique avec pareil les grains de
quartz feldspath qui sont dedans
et donc quand je dis on va regarder la
quantité d'énergie que ces minéraux ont
absorbé et on va le diviser par la
vitesse à laquelle cette énergie a été
absorbée donc vitesse qu'on espère
constante et ça ça va nous mener un âge
et lâche va correspondre en fait à la
dernière chauffe ou la dernière ou
dernier éclairage de ces minéraux
donc tu y penses huysman quoi on dette
l'enfouissement exactement 1 grains de
quartz se balade dans l'air voilà parce
que c'est un milieu humilié en forme il
ya du vent etc
il se dépose la toute l'énergie qu'il
avait reçu précédemment du fait qu'il a
été éclairée est parti et une fois qu'il
est enfoui s'agit comme une petite
batterie il va recevoir la libye subit
une fin est soumis à la radioactivité
naturelle mais comme il est enfoui
il va enregistrer cette radioactivité si
jamais il était remis à la lumière pour
lui de voir
or émission de lumière et il perdrait
toute l'énergie qu'il a reçus
précédemment
c'est par ce fait c'est des cycles c'est
vraiment comme une batterie qu'on va
charger et décharger suivant qu'elle est
exposé à des radiations dans le noir ou
qu'elle est éclairée donc la lumière
reboot le quartz la lumière ou la
chauffe d'adobe 0 mais reboot le poisson
on appelle ça une remise à zéro ou un
blanchiment quand il s'agit la lumière
donc là où vie de la pile
et si jamais on la met dans la terre à
l'abri de la lumière
eh ben on recharge notre patrie a break
après à la radioactivité naturelle par
la radioactivité naturelle et alors
comment mesure cette quantité d'énergie
justement c'est que plus l'échantillon à
rester longtemps soumis à la
radioactivité naturelle plus la pile est
chargé plus la quantité de lumière qu'il
va émettre
il est soumis lui même une stimulation
lumineuse ou une chose est importante
d'accord quand il se remet à zéro de
gauche tous voila il dégage la lumière
est ovale mesurer cette quantité de
lumière qui va être d'autant plus grande
qu'il aura été irradiés beaucoup donc
longtemps après ça marche bien si aussi
la vitesse d'enfouissement est bonne
c'est à dire qu'il faut un environnement
de dépôt qui est voilà il faut pas qu'il
ya une exposition comme j'étais parmi
les pavages désertique qui sont voilà il
faut qu'il ya des très bonnes conditions
d'enfouissement plutôt rapide alors il
ya un an il ya tout un tas de pierres
effectivement parce que nous quand on va
regarder par exemple qu'on va mesurer le
débit de dose cosmique
on va regarder souvent ça va dépendre de
la de l'épaisseur d'enfouissement mais
on sait bien que cette épaisseur de
refoulement elle a varié vous trotter
temps mais on va quand même prendre la
l'épaisseur actuelle bon donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut quand même que
l'échantillon et était enfouie
relativement rapidement
bon c'est pas le
la partie du débit de dose qui est la
plus là le débit de dose la vitesse à
laquelle ils enregistrent la bossa c'est
pas la partie du débit dose la plus
importante mais on a aussi d'autres
problèmes vis-à-vis par exemple dont on
dit ça doit être constant ce débit de
dose sauf que dès qu'il ya de l'eau qui
se baladent el balad aussi les radios et
les rend donc bon on n'est pas sûre à
200% que notre débit 2 et n'est pas un
petit peu changé en bien la qualité les
gens voilà typiquement dans les endroits
où on voit que ça a été briefé fier dans
les années croît tous les abris sous
roche que ça a été une brèche ification
relativement récente
moi je ne suis pas trop partant rich
ification j'ai réussi fication basse et
la formation de carbonate d'une façon
massive qui vous vraiment prendre le
sédiment au mess voilà oui la poudre
c'est ça le problème c'est l'eau qui va
circuler l'eau circule et avec la
circulation d'eau allant même de
l'uranium elle emmène alors elle apporte
où elle enlève et qui paraît pour le
potassium respect là d un petit peu et
donc par exemple dans l'est ou dans les
séries par exemple et qui sont issus de
d'érosion où il ya eu des phénomènes de
re d'érosion où on a remis à l'air libre
des échantillons puis après ils ont été
enfouies si on n'a pas comment dire
cette expertise
ça peut être effectivement un billet
aussi par rapport à cette datation c'est
ce qui pourrait expliquer par exemple
des inversions si on fait une séquence
stratigraphique et puis qu'on fait
plusieurs âges aux aisselles et puis
qu'on se rend compte qu'il ya des haches
qui sont pas cohérents là il faut
vraiment aller corps et l'esa et
croisées avec les bains ce que disent
les sédimentologue les géologues et puis
d'autres méthodes comme les sols loi et
c'est assez en fait pour louer c'est là
ce que j'aime pas ce que je dis ce
moment c'est que l'équation d'ajourner
le même c'est une des plus simples où
toute la liste
qu'est ce que c'est juste un rapport
entre l'énergie totale cumulée dans le
crâne quartz et la vitesse à laquelle
les cumuler
division on peut pas faire plus simple
sauf que quand on développe en fait les
termes surtout du du dénominateur avec
le débit de dose là on se retrouve avec
25 paramètres
donc c'est une méthode qui est lente et
qui si un problème sur un des paramètres
mais c'est difficile en fait on se dit
tiens cette date elle al'air folie qu il
est
c'est très difficile de pointer le
paramètre défaut des fonds c'est pas si
c'est si c'est l'énergie cumulé qu'on a
mesurée qui était mal mesurés parce
qu'on s'est planté selon le protocole
était pas le bon ou si il ya aussi ces
problèmes de mesure
cette méthode là la méthode est celle
elle et elle marche mais pour les
périodes plus récente qu'un million
d'années il ya eu des tests de fait je
crois mais notamment dans le rift sur
des échantillons qui était qui
approchait le million d'années mais pour
l'instant personne n'a réussi à dater
des échantillons aussi aussi vieux c'est
surtout une méthode
bon allez utiliser aussi sur par les
milieux holocène east mais là c'est une
méthode qui est un petit peu confrontés
à beaucoup d'autres méthodes
d'adaptation pour l'holocène sur les 10
derniers millénaires il ya énormément de
méthodes de datation qui sont très
précises et notamment en archéologie et
là c'est vrai qu'il faut être dans un
environnement très bon au niveau de
l'enfouissement parce que niveau de la
confrontation avec les autres méthodes
ça peut moi j'ai en souvenir par exemple
sur des environnements la cus dans des
carottages des comparaisons de datation
ou sl il ya une quinzaine d'années bon
çà çà çà c'était ça ne marchait pas bien
mais après bon c'est vrai que c'est une
méthode qui fait cette fois sur les
intervalles de temps et là il non mais
c'est après c'est une méthode aussi que
ce que j'en comprends c'est qu'elle a
surtout l'avantagé d'être applicable
absolument à tous parce que du sable il
y en a partout tout le temps et c'est
son gros avantage c'est que les grains
de quartz et des fêtes spets et les
minéraux qu'on le trouve le plus sur
terre donc il y en a quasiment dans tous
les sites archéologiques 1 c'est très
très rare qu'on n'ait pas de quoi faire
mais les datations voilà après il faut
que ce soit des milieux quand même
favorable donc si c'est un fonds de
grottes avec des sédiments qui sont
arrivés par le fond de la grotte qu'elle
est bien noir il y aura pas eu
d'exposition à la lumière
et donc c'est juste ça va pas marcher
par exemple en rhône alpes on a pas mal
de séquences de l'os puisqu'en fait les
glaciers des alpes descendait à très bas
en fait dans ce qu'on appelle le lobe
glaciaire lyonnais c'est à dire qu aux
portes de lyon il ya vingt mille ans il
y avait un glacier ça c'était la
dernière glaciation à l'avant dernière
glaciation le glacier on appelle le
glacier du rhône descendait jusqu'à lyon
et en se retirant il ya eu des vents
donc très sec qui ont trié les
particules qui était broyée sous le
glacier c'est ce qu'on appelle donc les
leçons que la base des le piémont en
fait des monts du lyonnais
il ya énormément de placage de leusse il
ya également des deux dans la vallée de
la saône qui sont très bien datés par la
méthode osl parce que le lien
environnement de l'enfouissement ses
doigts homogène
voilà ces méthodes qui est régulièrement
utilisé pour dater décide par exemple du
paléolithique moyen voilà aux alentours
de 2 au delà de quarante mille ans sur
des sites à 70 mille ans ça très bien
entre avait très bien marché dans les
murs par exemple gêné cette question sur
la radioactivité donc ça ça dépend de la
radioactivité du sol si j'ai bien
compris mais si on a un quartz qui est
enfoui en bretagne dans un endroit où il
ya beaucoup de radioactivité naturelle
est ce qu'on va ce qu'on s'attend à
trouver un âge différent du coût de 2,6
et enterré quelque part dans bassin de
paris quoi alors admettons qu'ils aient
exactement et qui sait que ces deux
quartz et se soient déposés au même
moment
si on travaille bien on va trouver
effectivement le même âge ce qui va être
différent c'est justement que il y en a
un qui va être plus irradiés que l'autre
donc son sa dose c'est l'énergie total
accumulé qu'on appelle des plats dose
équivalente va être plus grande en
bretagne que dans paris mais comme le
débit de dose on va mesurer en bretagne
m également plus grand que celui qu on
la mesure à paris si on travaille bien
et on va trouver normalement les deux
rapports devraient donner
la même chose c'est une réponse
redoutablement précise et efficace
ok et la dernière méthode c'est le src
ça dans cette catégorie alors c'est une
méthode qui est très voisines de la
luminescence stimuler dans la mesure où
elle va reposer un petit peu sur les
mêmes le même principe de deux charges
piéger en fait alors j'ai pas expliquer
ça pour la luminescence on parlait de la
batterie et c'est ce qui se passe c'est
que dans au sein du cristal du quartz
il ya différents les charges companies
électrons donc ils sont tour des atomes
dans le cristal peuvent avoir différents
niveaux d'énergie
on va parler d'un état fondamental d'un
état excité et entre ces deux états à
cause des pièces enfin à cause des
pièges à cause des défauts du christ au
il va y avoir des niveaux où l'appel des
qui vont servir de pièges en fait qui
vont qui vont piéger les électrons et
c'est là c'est là dans ces pièges que
les électrons s'accumuler au fur et à
mesure qu'ils sont que le cristal et
irradie et donc quand on fait la
luminescence stimuler on va éclairer
l'échantillon et c'est ça qui va faire
qui va permettre aux électrons de sortir
de ces pièges et c'est en sortant qui
vont émettre une lumière ce qui se
recombinent etc enfin bref je veux pas
rentrer dans les détails
donc on va mesurer la quantité
d'électrons piégé grâce à la lumière
émise alors que en pour l'électronique
une résonance on va regarder en fait on
va utiliser une autre propriété de ces
électrons piégée alors cette propriété
en fait c'est que si jamais les
électrons qui sont 18 trous une appel
célibataires sont mis dans un champ
magnétique intense il ils ont entre
l'appel à spin la notion de vue physique
quantique
cliquez alors points
n'illustre des fois comme étant la
rotation de l'électron ils peuvent dire
tourner dans un sens ou dans l'autre
donc ils ont spin qui va faire comment
c'est un petit aimant soit vers le haut
vers le bas et donc quand on les met
dans cet aimant les spins s'oriente
comme des petits aimants dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
et si on met un autre champ magnétique
avec la bonne fréquence qui va bien au
delà des élections me tourner et ça ça
va créer une absorption d'énergie etc la
mesure de cette absorption d'énergie
qu'on va mesurer et qui va correspondre
en fait sur l'intensité de cette
absorption va correspondre au nombre
d'électrons qui sont piégés
si twitter je suis pas complètement sûr
d'avoir compris comment ça ça relit avec
le temps qui a passé
et bien parce que admettons qu au départ
n'est pas du tout d'électrons piéger les
notes remises à zéro alors ça va être
pour les cohortes on mesure les portes
aussi par pes et la musique donc la
datation des crânes force pour se faire
éventuellement cette matière là mais
pour l'instant on va surtout travailler
sur les dents c'est le principal objet
date et l'émail dentaire et quand ils se
forment en fait il n'ya pas les électro
quand même le cristal se forme on veut
dire que les électrons sont pas piéger
au fort à mesure que la dent est irradié
belgique 3 vont aller dans les pièges et
donc la pensée l'intensité en fait on va
on va faire comme pour la luminescence
ainsi pouvoir en fait c'est la quantité
des radiations qui correspond au nombre
d'électrons piégé donc plus il ya
d'électrons piégé plus l'énergie
absorbée quand on va mettre les
électrons dans le champ magnétique avec
notre championne magnétique
perpendiculaire et la bonne fréquence
qui va bien pour les faire tourner plus
cette absorption d'énergie va être
importante sont faites et donc on va
pouvoir remonter a en quelque sorte la
quantité d l'expo piégée qui correspond
donc
autant d'irradiation et on remonte
jusqu'à corps avec cette technique
alors celle ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on peut remonter plus loin que avec
la luminescence stimuler ou au delà de
500 mille ans donc presque jusqu'à un
million d'années vont rarement ses
habitudes qui est bien utilisé en
préhistoire
voilà et ça permet de dater directement
les fossiles tant qu'il ya des temps
c'est ça tant qu'à des dents voilà alors
on va date et aïda sens plus facilement
des dents de gros bovidés bien larges
que des dents de fossiles humains
forcément ce jour paraît parce que c'est
un peu destructif ça et là mais ça c'est
fait je sais qu'il ya eu des dettes
comme ça le problème là avec la méthode
c'est que le sur les dents des danses et
des pontes à uranium donc au cours du
temps elles vont absorber l'uranium qui
se trouve dans les sédiments dans
l'environnement autour et il faut
pouvoir bas tenir compte du fait que du
coup le débit de dose il a évolué au
cours du temps et donc maintenant ce
qu'on fait souvent faim systématiquement
c'est qu'ils croisent avec l' uranium
thorium et ils vont regarder il utilise
l'iranien le thorium en fait pour
modéliser la corporation d'uranium dans
la dent et donc modéliser la variation
du débit de dose je suis mitigé quant à
la nouvelle d'apprendre que mes dents
sont des pompes à uranium est ce qu'il
n'ya pas beaucoup d'éléments radioactifs
dans les bananes parce que moi je mange
beaucoup de bananes ya là beaucoup
potassium dans les bananes donc dû
potasser en quarantaine et banale sont
là les approches d'un compteur geiger
muller ça crépite
mais voilà le raid le potassium
autant que je sache ce corps pour moins
que le que l'uranium d'accord y'a pas de
déballage auquel je suis rassuré mais
dans ne pompe pas la radioactivité des
bananes est ok mais je crois qu'on a
déjà on a bien fait le tour des méthodes
fondées sur les dommages
donc du coup on peut passer à la
catégorie suivante les méthodes fondées
sur les cinétique chimique l eau dans
laquelle on à l'hydratation de
l'obsidienne et la rationalisation des
acides aminés oui alors penser des
méthodes qui enfin moi en tout cas sur
toutes les études que j'ai pu faire en
afrique c'est pas des méthodes que j'ai
vu beaucoup et peut-être que je vais
parce que par exemple je travaille pas
dans des zones où il ya beaucoup de
petits diène j'ai lu des articles dans
la semaine nous disaient oui la méthode
de l'obsidienne c'est beaucoup beaucoup
utilisé moi j'ai vu un article récent
là-dessus mais je sais que là ces deux
méthodes ont été remises un peu au goût
du jour
il ya deux ans il ya des articles avec
des nouvelles méthodologies qui sont
sortis dont il y aura peut-être plus
d'application dans le futur docly
datation de l'obsidienne ça s'applique
aux opticienne évidemment et les
obsidienne cédé vers volcanique est ce
qu'on va date et là c'est la taille en
fait d'une sévère parce qu'elles ont des
très bonnes propriétés de taille donc
elle aurait été beaucoup utilisé les
génériques pour parler les hommes
préhistoriques pour faire des jolies
outils à c'est très très bon en général
c'est très fin donc on date la dernière
taille de l'obsidienne en fait qu'en
taille au départ la coupe et tout tout
brillant toute fraîche et puis il ya une
patine en fait qui va se former avec une
épaisseur qui va grandir au cours du
temps à cause de l'eau qui est contenu
dans le vert et dans l'atmosphère et 7,7
croissance de 2,7 pâti de cette
épaisseur de de cette couche là elle
elle est fonction du temps alors le
problème de cette méthode c'est que
c'est très dépendant de l'environnement
de la température et de l'hygrométrie et
de la nature de l'obsidian ça va pas
être le même ce n'est deux sur deux vers
différents ça va pas tout à fait la même
chose
donc ça c'est ça marche assez bien en
datation relative sur divers identique
dans un même site etc
on parle de dire celui-là il a été
taillé un celui-là mais par contre pour
une datation absolue là il faut de faire
une sorte de calibration en fait pour
voir à quelle est la vitesse pour cette
de cette croissance de couches en
fonction de l'environnement du site ce
qui paraît tout ça c'est pascal qui
s'applique sur les outils en obsidienne
ont quasi quasi-exclusivement je suppose
je vois pas l'intérêt est surtout ça
l'intérêt je sais pas j'ai lu après il
peut y avoir des éclats spécialiste de
l'intérêt c'est de pouvoir dater des
outils qui ont été taillés par à un
moment donné alors que bon s'ils sont
6es d éclat naturel bon ils peuvent
avoir été fait à différentes périodes de
temps les éclat naturel après on peut
imaginer aussi que comme ça vers du dha
volcanisme et y aura peut-être les
laissant dans l'étuvé que c'était avec
largo qui va bien pour casser par l'ars
oi rebond plutôt que par le le ver
lui-même et les coulées de lave je pense
pas comme en date les couples et donc
signal
ok et donc c'est une méthode qui se base
beaucoup sur l'altération à cause de
l'eau ce qui sur une planète
essentiellement couverte de ça peut être
problématique si je comprends de là je
ne sais pas s'il faut voir les choses
comme ça il faut qu'ils et la soie du
spécialiste la formation de la patine
comment les quais les procédures
la question c'est en fonction de la
température et de l'hygrométrie comment
la vitesse à laquelle cette patine va se
former a changé donc il faut pouvoir
déterminer quelle a été la vitesse qui
correspond à ce ver donné dans ce site
donné sur le temps il faut pas que ça
ait trop évolué au cours du temps aussi
ça qui est problématique
donc c'est un peu sais m'arrêter si je
me trompe c'est un peu comme si on
essayait de date est un métal par sa
couche d'oxydation fait c'est plus ou
moins ça oui on peut voir ça comme ça où
est-ce qu encore une fois je poussais
métaphore trop loin le métal il va
peut-être enfin j'ai jamais vu au fait
personne n'a jamais dit que le métal se
rouiller avec une vitesse constante dans
des conditions si ainsi des conditions
atmosphériques reste constante
alors voilà c'est censé être le cadre de
l'auxiliaire d'accord mais appréciable
mais c'est toujours la constance qui est
la clé de la datation dont clara s'est
mise à sion d'être collage ressemble à
une horloge et pas un truc qui fait une
seconde et puis une seconde journée puis
une seconde
c'est une horloge poids et la race
émulation des acides aminés
alors là on est sur des organismes
fossiles donc l'écho qui dope d'autruche
les eaux et on va date-là la mort de
l'organisme là on fait les acides aminés
c'est là une des molécules qui sont dans
les protéines et on va se servir d'une
propriété de symétrie de ces de ces
molécules qui essaient arrondissement on
compare souvent aux mains en fait elles
peuvent être soit comme des mains
gauches sont comme des mains droites
mais c'est la même molécule justel a pas
la même forme ça se superposent pas en
fait c'est symétrie par un port un plan
et donc il ya une propriété de ces
acides qui fait que du vivant 2
animal c'est que des mains gauches et
puis une fois qu'il est mort eh ben il
ya une partie de ma gauche qui vont se
transformer en main droite
je ne sais pas expliquer pourquoi je
sais même pas ce mot c'est exactement
pourquoi ça fait ça mais c'est cette
transformation se fait avec une vitesse
qui dans des conditions de température
constante est également en constante
le problème c'est que je demande suivant
les différentes températures cette
vitesse n'est pas la même donc à nouveau
il faut pouvoir calibré et faire des
hypothèses par rapport à la stabilité de
cette température alors dans des
sédiments enfouis bon je pense pas que
la température varie énormément mais il
me semble qu'un degré ça fait déjà pas
mal de différences des environnements
très stables comme les grottes où
théoriquement bombe à la température
évolué au cours du temps
alors si on est dans un environnement
des sites de plein air par exemple dans
un milieu désertique
il ya eu des phases des articles des
fades humide ou au cours des grands
cycles climatiques quoi ça c'est plus
risqué toujours la sélection de jean la
sélection de l'échantillon connaître
reconnaître son échantillon fait voilà
play faut pouvoir comme monter un peu
l'histoire dû faire des hypothèses sur
cette ampera turf un bon voilà il faut
là faudrait vendre discute avec un
spécialiste et localement les personnes
qui ont repris la méthode ya deux ans là
pour voir comment ils ont réussi à
contourner le ces problèmes là je sais
pas exactement mais voilà donc c'est une
méthode qui permet d'aller de quelques
milliers à quelques millions d'années
quand même
alors tu sais même pas ce que suivant
les articles on regarde on n'a pas tout
à fait les mêmes informations
voilà non c'est mais les acides aminés
ça ça me paraît ça me paraît beaucoup
quelques millions d'années pour des
acides aminés comme ben j'ai lu ça sur
un article alors je ne sais pas voilà
parce que sur un autre j'ai vu de 470
milles environ donc j'espère faudrait
vérifier les sources soulagé par cette
activité est long bien je dis ça mais on
a trouvé des du collagène de dinosaures
de 70 millions d'années donc en fait
peut-être qu'en théorie on pourrait les
dates et parce qu'à un moment donné en
fait la transformation quand il va pas
s'arrêter quand la moitié des mains
gauches du département être tous
transformés en main droite
ça va s'il ya un espoir ou le déquilibre
qui se fait et ça va pas aller plus loin
donc cette on remontera pas aussi loin
que les dinosaures mais voilà bon donc
cette journée deux méthodes sont pas des
métaux fins rationalisation et puis l
hydratation quotidienne c'est pas des
méthodes dont on peut attendre d'écran
de précision non plus comme les mythes
de isotopique à environ 10% si ça
resterait considérée comme une datation
absolue dans le sens où on obtient une
date celle de chiffrer le fécond que la
date soit pas précise n'empêche pas que
ce soit quand même un âge chiffré sa ces
précisions justesse et tout ça c'est pas
d'accord
et maman passe aux méthodes suivantes à
savoir les méthodes stratigraphique
alors là on va se tourner vers xavier du
coup parce que là on va être dans des
méthodes beaucoup plus relative en fait
que absolue absolue c'est vraiment le
domaine de la physique
voilà ça va être plus le dos mais de là
alors il ya un an quand on entend
relatif on va se dire ah ça va être
moins bien mais en fait pas forcément
mes pieds encore une fois il n'ya pas de
méthode qu'ils soient bonnes ou
mauvaises ya c'est l'ensemble des
méthodes tout croisée de toutes façons
qui recroiser créé la puissance de la
datation là une seule méthode comme
comme vous venez de le dire chantal il
ya précision et justesse on peut avoir
une date très précise très précises qui
soit complètement faux exactement et les
précise qu'elle a dû changer de juste
d'ailleurs plus la barre d'erreur est
grande plus en a chance de couvrir
ok donc les méthodes stratigraphique on
commence par la calibration astronomique
a alors ça c'est une méthode bon qui va
marcher qui va être intéressante que si
on travaille sur des intervalles de
temps long c'est à dire que si mon
travail sur une période de quarante
mille ans il n'y aura pas possibilité
d'aller regarder les cycles astronomique
bon alors ça marche très bien pour des
environnements sédimentaires rythmé qui
ont un lien très fort avec le climat sur
le long terme
typiquement des environnements lacustre
ou des environnements marins qui vont
enregistrer qui sont des fenêtres
ouvertes sur le climat et qui vont
enregistrer à différentes échelles ça
peut être à l'échelle de l'année ou à
l'échelle des mois des saisons mais les
échelles dont on parle actuellement la
l'été sur l'astronomie du climat elle
gère le climat sur des échelles de temps
qui sont comprises c'est inférieur à
milan c'est la théorie de milankovitch
cdc des intervalles de temps qu'ils sont
deux cent mille ans quarante mille ans
vingt mille ans ils sont liés à pois en
fait ils sont liés à des variations par
exemple pour celle de 100000 en scellier
tout simplement à l'excentricité de la
terre en fête l'orbité de la terre
décrit soit autour du sol est un cercle
ou alors plutôt une ellipse
alors ça c'est très intéressant parce
que ça va un petit peu géré 2
pour expliquer simplement la distance de
la terre par rapport au soleil donc ces
cycles de deux cent mille ans déjà ils
ont un impact pas en europe sur les
glaciations mais par exemple quand on
travaille dans le rift sur le bassin du
turkana qui est un bassin pas les eaux
lacustres
quand on va travailler sur des
intervalles qui vont être déjà deux on
va dire à 500 mille ans pour ce sont
intéressants et bien on va voir que ça
peut avoir un impact ce cycle de lectra
l'excentricité sur les variations du
niveau l'accusent paléo l'appui du lac
turkana parce que ça a un effet sur la
mousson on est en pleine zone
comment dire où la mousson à fort impact
même si on est dans un bassin très aride
parce qu'il ya l'aumône au fleuve omo
puis d'autres fleuves qui n'existe plus
actuellement mais qui alimentait se bat
ça la puce
alors ça c'est l'excentricité ensuite il
ya l'obliquité l'obliquité c'est tout
simplement à l'inclinaison de la terre 1
l'inclinaison de la terre elle varie un
peu ça c'est un cycle qui joue plus à
sur quarante mille ans alors tous ces
cycles ça on se rajouter les uns aux
autres hein mais il va y avoir un signal
plus fort
bon ça par exemple sur le bassin du
turkana
ça joue normalement moins on n'a pas
trop de deux semaines il ya un autre
cycle c'est le stick de la précession là
pour l'expliqué très simplement
maintenant qu'on a expliqué donc
l'excentricité avec ce système de leur
guide de autour du soleil donc avec en
forme de roue en forme de serpent en
forme d'ellipse ensuite on a eu
l'obliquité et ensuite donc la pression
c'est tout simplement que la terre elle
va donc s'incliner à selon ces taxes
mais elle va faire comme un mouvement de
toupie et ça ça sur les hommes par
exemple tropicale intertropicale ça va
aussi avoir un effet sur ces zones qui
vont au cours du temps si on modifie ces
paramètres
ça va avoir un impact très fort sur
l'humidité atmosphérique par exemple et
aussi sur l'insolation par exemple quand
on dit l'excentricité c'est un lien
aussi avec l'installation alors
l'excentricité gili ainsi plaçant milan
mais c'est aussi quatre cent mille ans
incessants cassant milan alors par
exemple sur les séries du turkana
quand on travaille sur des séries rythme
et donc sédimentaires typiquement en
milieu lacustre des fenêtres comme jeudi
ouverture sur le climat avec des apports
hydrologue
qu'ils viennent de la zone tropicale eh
bien on va avoir ce signal de façon très
forte alors les chronologie relative on
les appelle aussi relative parce
qu'elles ont besoin des chronologies
absolu pour ce pour ce pour se fixer
elles sont flottants c'est chronologique
c'est à dire qui à un moment donné on a
des cycles comme on a dit un code-barres
aussi ça fournit un espèce de
code-barres mais il ya un moment donné
le code-barres il faut le fixer et donc
pour ça il faut avoir des points où on
va se fixer dont classe ou dans le
bassin du turkana par exemple on utilise
les datations sur les les dépôts
volcaniques
c'est un peu la même chose pour une
méthode comparé à tout à l'heure pour le
paléomagnétisme c'est aussi une méthode
relative et si on n'a pas de point pour
fixer cette chronologie qui est un petit
peu flottante enfin sauf que le panier
this si on a la chance d'avoir bon on en
parle à tout à l'heure mais si on a la
chance d'avoir un coup de barre très
précis et là on peut peut-être s'avancer
mais c'est les méthodes qui ont besoin
de point de fixation
donc voilà la méthode de gens parlent de
chronologie astronomique tout ça ça ça
soit sur les théories de milankovitch
milutin milankovic qui a compris ça que
en fait on pouvait même calculer ces
cycles est actuellement bon moi je le
jeu il y aller par exemple les travaux
de lascars qui ont calculé ils ont fait
des algorithmes et voilà on connaît on a
des courbes qui forment comme ça des
oscillations et donc on peut on peut
comme ça une fois qu'on a des séries
sédimentaires et qu on les transforme en
termes de cycle regarder si par exemple
un série de onid commune ainsi que de
haut niveau lacustre s'il va avoir une
répétition tous les quarante mille ans
tous les mains milan tous les sens milan
est derrière quel est le paramètre
climatique qui explique cela en
l'occurrence a par exemple dans le
bassin du turkana ya un signal fort de
lier à l'excentricité ouvrir son
excentricité la terre par exemple on
sait qu'il ya des hauts niveaux la piste
régulièrement tous les sens milan 1 400
mille ans parce que c'est lié à
l'association qui dit plus d'insolation
dans la zone tropicale qui le bassin
versant du dur du bassin turkana dit
plus d'humilité atmosphérique et qui dit
plus l'humidité atmosphérique plus débat
peut enfin plus de ce qu'il fait plus
chaud et plus humide
il y aura beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
d'eau mobilisés dans le lac et le niveau
du lac
monter ça par exemple on s'en sert dans
ces séries dans ces séries qui sont
c'est ce qui s'appelle la cyclo
stratigraphie donc c'est forcément bien
on a donc cédé série géologique
sédimentaires qui sont qui ont quelques
dates par ci par là qui ont été
déterminées par datation absolue donc
l'argon et dans ces séries sédimentaires
on reconnaît des cycles sédimentaires
qui correspondent à des événements
climatiques alors pas d événement
justement il faut que déjà que le
sédiment l'alternance climatique voilà
il faut voilà il faut à salim en rythme
et ça ça il faut vraiment et c'est la
base il faut un environnement de dépôt
comme dans les océans où il ya une
accumulation continue au cours du temps
il faut qu'elle soit la plus con tinue
possible donc souvent pas scellé dans le
milieux continental ça va être des
bassins sédimentaires comme dans les
milieux de rift je pense notamment au
bassin
comment dire le lac baïkal j'ai fait ma
thèse justement sur le lac baïkal donc
c'est le lac le plus profond au monde
c'est le plus grand réservoir d'eau
douce et là en fait il va y avoir une
espèce de plus sédimentaires qui va
tomber au fond du du lac
un peu comme dans les océans et tous est
lié aussi à la vie dans le lac c'est à
dire que souvent il ya des organismes
qui vit et qui meurt dans et qui vont
être donc ils vont se déposer au fond de
fond du lac ou au fond de l'océan et ses
pluies de sédiments soit organique soit
biologique
elles sont liées à ce qui se passe au
niveau climatique et donc comme j'ai dit
à plusieurs cycles donc c'est souvent
c'est lié aux saisons mais c'est aussi
sur le long terme
ben si par exemple en zone tropicale ou
intertropicale la variation de la
mousson elle donc elle est très
dépendante des cycles astronomiques sur
le long terme
donc ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on va regarder sur le il faut des
séquences très long qui ont une
accumulation continue conduite en
d'accord elle concrètement si on trouve
un fossile donc on va reprendre la
situation de tout à l'heure on est dans
la région du lac turkana on trouve un
fossile
on arrive à l'adapter en fonction de 2h
argon wind potassium un bon parcours à
gombe
et si on veut savoir précisément
exactement où il se trouve entre ces
deux âges là on va utiliser ses
alternant
eh bien les accords alors pas où il se
situe au niveau de ces alternances de
sédimentation et ça va nous permettre de
dire ça correspond à tel passage du
cycle de milankovitch par exemple voilà
ça la renforcer comment dire nos
certitudes sur les âges je pense
notamment par exemple à des cithares que
le kobaïen qui sont systématiquement
situés sur des pâles et aux plages donc
en fête au bord du bassin du turkana
c'est donc un très grand c'est le plus
grand lac en milieu désertique au monde
c'est un la quittes saleh en doré hic
est en fait cours du temps quand on
remonte dans le temps sur des périodes
de quatre millions d'années il ya eu des
palais au lac est en fait sur les berges
de ces paléologue successifs s'est
installé les hominidés les hominidés est
en fait donc à chaque fois qu'ils
s'installaient sur les îles se
rapprochait parce qu'à cette époque là
c'était un milieu d'eau douce alors que
maintenant c'est un milieu salée pour
des raisons de bon la ccd raisons
géologiques paléogéographiques et donc
qu'il s'approchait du lac qui est un
milieu de douces ils s'installèrent et
donc au cours du temps les plages se
sont bougés puisque le niveau monte le
niveau baisse le niveau monde le niveau
baisse et donc on a des séries de paléo
plage les sites s'installe dessus et
quand on fait la cyclo stratigraphie de
ses pas les plages et qu'on aura la
chance de pouvoir dater sûr on va
pouvoir se rendre compte effectivement
que le par exemple cycle à 100 millions
il est présent le site à 400 mille ans
aussi et du coup ou peu comment dire
contrainte dès l'âge de 6 taux de l'oat
ya mais je pense à des six pions qui
sont datés à 2,2 millions d'années 2,3
millions d'années et qui sont datés par
exemple retombées volcanique à 2.33
millions d'années et puis après la
prochaine c'est le kb s le fameux kbs
qui est l'ancien transition plie au
pléistocène jusque dans les zus qu'en
2009 où là on a décidé de changer la
limite du plus haut que l'estonienne a
justement aux tubes de duke abs 1 87
million d'années et là on l'a changé à
2,6 millions d'années donc là on a un
intervalle de temps entre 87 et 3 3 mais
on est où il se passe donc plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'années on sait
pas vraiment où il est donc pour savoir
où on est on utilise notamment sur ses
plats paléo plage
à peu près trois ou quatre palets aux
plages sur certains valent deux
intervalles de temps et du coup on peut
utiliser la cistre cyclo stratigraphie
pour pour contraindre l'âge permet de
réduire la marge d'erreur encore en plus
oued et datation absolue en fait c'est
vraiment complément des datation absolue
en complément et puis c'est aussi dont
consignes on n'a pas le choix il
faudrait utiliser calculé par exemple un
taux de sédimentation qui serait
constant entre donc entre le tube que
j'ai expliqué l'avocat nique à 2003 3 33
millions d'années après le tube canaux
floraux et puis on a ensuite le tuf le
kb s voilà mais malheureusement les
l'ethos alimentation ils ont varié
puisque les environnements dépôt changé
c'est à dire que soit on est
complètement dans le lac
et là on a des sédiments une
segmentation argileuse et les taux de
ces limitations dans les argiles sont
très bas souvent dans le monde à je
prends l'exemple du lac turkana du lac
baïkal
c'est moins d'un millimètre par an voilà
après quand ça se transforme en plage
plus l'environnement l'énergie va être
forte plus elle va être important pour
déplacer les sédiments par exemple et
les environnements où vient donc les
vagues qui déplace les sables dès que
les particules ou à de plus grosses
forcément il va y avoir des
accumulations plus important de
sédiments et on peut pas appliquer bien
évidemment le même taux de sédimentation
ce serait une erreur là par exemple
quand on est dans des environnements
sableux on va dépasser plusieurs
centimètres par an si on ramène sa part
ans mais bon là quand on travaille sur
le bassin turkana on va plutôt parler
d'eux sur mire donc là ça va être ça
typiquement 50 cm par milan c'était
intéressant en fait parce que là on fait
donc une émission sur les méthodes de
datation qui sont utilisés mais c'est
vrai qu'on prend pas le temps de couvrir
toutes les choses qu'on ne de enfin qui
ne sont pas utilisés parce qu'elles sont
pas suffisamment fiables comme par
exemple les taux de sédimentation qui
n'arrête pas de fluctuer par exemple
c'est quelque chose qui revient souvent
dans encore une fois cherché des pseudos
archéologie stxe les créationnistes de
mesure et des épaisseurs de sédiments et
dire de vous voyez ça peut plus déposer
en un million d'années
à chaque tout ça oui mais le taux de
sédimentation c'est quelque chose qu'on
sait une donnée qu'on ne maîtrise pas
forcément quoi
oui alors il ya après quand on connaît
bien les environnements moi je pense
notamment sur le bassin du turkana on
sait pas ce qui a eu plusieurs travaux
maintenant depuis depuis des années le
30 40 ans on sait que tel type
d'environnement va avoir tel type de
toutes ces lits mentation par exemple on
sait que dans les argiles ça va être
plutôt 15 cm par milliers d'années
maximum voire un petit peu moins et puis
dès qu'on va être sur les environnements
de plage ou sableux ça va être 50 cm par
milliers d'années ça on le sait parce
que si on a eu la chance d'avoir
d'autres environnements daté du même
type par des tubes volcaniques plus
rapprochée voilà donc du coup on peut si
on a une séquence stratigraphique on
peut faire ce qu'on appelle des modèles
d'âge c'est à dire que si oui pour que
le faire il faut avoir au moins deux
âges d'un lavage au sommet au mieux en
avoir un ou au milieu donc en
l'occurrence la regardons pour pouvoir
contrôler si le modèle d'âge y est bon
et par exemple si on a la chance d'avoir
par exemple simplement trois types
d'environnement avec ce qu'on appelle en
anglais mais le off shore ça veut dire
qu'on a une si nîmes en tation argileuse
parce que même si on a des sites
archéologiques à 10 km du lac actuelle
on peut avoir tout d'un coup dans les
séquences stratigraphique des argiles
parce que c'est quand le lac était
remonté donc quand on va traverser ces
stratigraphique ces environnements
stratigraphique on peut faire un modèle
d'âge où on va donc appliqué sur par
exemple je ne sais pas moi il ya dix
mètres d'argile on va appliquer ce taux
de saignement tation puis ensuite on va
avoir cinq mètres de sédimentation qui
est proche de la plage où on va dire que
et bien c'est 20 cm par milieu d'année
puis après on arrive sur la plage avec
50 cm parmi les délits wouah donc
calculer ça par rapport aux épées ça aux
épaisseurs on va l'appliquer se sait
tout sédimentation et si on arrive en
étant vraiment
comment dire honnête et en fonctionnant
en de façon aveugle est vraiment en
respectant les transitions stratigraphie
si on arrive à des résultats corrects
entre la base et le sommet que voilà on
a une cohérence en appliquant des zéros
plage de des bardes erreur oui ça peut
donner des bons résultats rôle fenoyl ou
bassin turkana quand même faut quand
même pouvoir contrôler il faut qu'on
trouve des points de contrôle pour quand
même avoir un contrôle sur ce qu'on fait
qu'ils soient assez stricte pas ample
erreur ce serait de faire on a une
adaptation à la base une séquence
stratigraphique de 40 m par exemple qui
est datée par une retombée volcaniques
comme celle du cac baisse par exemple
donc le fameux à l'ancienne tradition
paix ou leicester scène et puis on va
appliquer un taux de sédimentation sur
les 50 mètres mais on aura pas de
contrôle au sommet ça il faut pas c'est
tu sais on aura un âge au sommet miss
états unis sera fautif quoi on a une
chance
on a une petite chance que ce soit bon
d'accord et on peut faire le
paléomagnétisme dans la foulée c'est un
principe assez similaire au final oui
alors que c'est une méthode bas physique
mais c'est là pour un coût elle est
relative pourquoi leur relative donc
c'est basé sur en fait l'inversion des
pôles en fait actuellement le pôle nord
il est au bon endroit on va dire
mais au cours du temps ils s'inverse
c'est à dire que paul lors pas aller au
pôle sud et donc comment le mesure il
faut des environnements des propice à la
mesure du paléomagnétisme serre que les
particules magnétiques vont en sédiments
temps fixé l'orientation des pôles
voilà tout ça c'est pas visibles à
l'oeil nu
ces matériaux ferreux voilà les
matériaux ferreux et donc des mini m en
quoi voilà ces bois c'est ça c'est ça
respecte l'aimantation ça marche très
bien présent dans les sédiments tation
argileuse
voilà me faut un petit peu quand même de
sédimentation comment dire fine mais
avec des particules magnétiques et puis
donc quand on va faire une séquence
stratigraphique on va où c'est la
stratigraphie va être échantillonnés
avait qu'un pas régulier et huit par
mois 2 si on a bien mettre mon passé
d'échantillonner tous les cinq
centimètres ça montera pas le coup
puisque en fait on parle d' inversion
qui sont quand même
voilà par exemple âgées des exemples sur
un million d'années on peut avoir deux
voire trois versions voilà on va essayer
tout est championne et où les mettre par
exemple et on va voir un petit peu ce
que ça donne c'est une chronologie
relative parce qu'elle est flottante
elle a besoin d'avoir un point de
fixation pour voir de quelle inversion
magnétique on parle sauf si on a la
chance par exemple je pense à un exemple
très courtes très concret j'ai
l'impression qu'on a un peu raté une
étape dans l'explication dans le sens où
donc déjà il ya des inversions régulière
régulière non justement
juste avant c'est bien ça le truc
jusqu'à des inversions de temps en temps
des pôles des deux pôles mais ne sont
pas régulières ils ne sont pas l'intérêt
et c'est le pattern de ces inversions
justin voilà qui va qui va nous
intéresser puisque on va arriver à voir
ce pattern dans les sédiments est arrivé
à le retrouver dans une bagarre dans un
schéma d'inversion des mâchoires
électromagnétiques type
voilà là par exemple je prends ça c'est
entre ces antres entre l'actuel et puis
donc les cinq six derniers millions
d'années on voit c'est un espèce de
codes-barres et prendre un exemple très
concret
par exemple en 2015 a été publiée par
notre équipe qui travaille une équipe
française qui travaille dans le bassin
du turkana a été découvert des outils
lithiques dans des niveaux pliocène ça
c'est très anormales parce que
normalement donc comme les outils les
plus anciens son rôle de moyens ils sont
et trouver à 2,6 millions d'années donc
l'actuel ma limite du christ au ciel
donc ils sont payés cette semaine et où
comme on dit quaternaire c'est l'ère de
l'homme
l'art en fête en 2011 puisque la
découverte datait de 2011 mais il ya mis
plusieurs années à prouver que ces
outils taillés par l'homme avec des
modes on va dire pour simplifier très
primitif datait en fait de 3 3 millions
d'années donc ça veut dire qu'on a
reculé la chronologie de l'homme on va
dire l'humain en tant qu elle être
qu'ils pensent pour faire des schémas de
taille à 3,3 millions d'années comment
ça a été daté ce site à 3 de l'eau mais
cui qui s'appelle donc le nommer cui
comment at il été datés il ya eu deux
datation l'utilisé pas toujours les
mêmes dans le bassin du turc elle à
savoir l'arbre argon parce qu'il ya une
une retombée volcaniques qui s'appelle
le tour auto qui est qui et datés à 3,3
3.31 millions d'années
cette retombée volcanique a été trouvé à
400 mètres du site archéologique et il
ya une autre retombée volcaniques qui
est le tube l'étude du bord c3 c3
retomber volcaniques qui sont datés à
trois points 44 3.41 donc le problème
c'est que le site était au dessus de ces
de retomber et l'a donc est venu donc la
méthode du palio le magnétisme ou pour
partir de ces points de fixation faire
un échantillonnage voir quel était
l'état nation alors là il ya eu quand
même une chance incroyable c'est qu'on
tombe dans un intervalle bâtiaz de le
montrer par exemple si on était tombé
dans cet intervalle le temps ici par
exemple ça aurait été un petit peu
compliqué mais là en fait on tombe dans
un intervalle de temps où il y a des
inversions ce qu'on appelle des sucs
rhône où des crocs l'un est en fait
qu'ils sont plus rapprochés et
l'ajustement l'agencé que à 3,33
millions d'années il ya la transition
donc mammoth c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle c'est un support au nhs
il ya aussi le cas à 3,15 millions
d'années donc s'il n'avait pas vu le
point de fixation bon on n'aurait pas
suivre si c'était carrenard ou mammoth
mais grâce aux otages en dessous on sait
que et
le site archéologique est installé sur
une pâle et aux plages comme ce que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure et la paléo
plage est datée par la transition
mammoth go go c'est le prône une farce
méthode qui est très utilisé dans le rif
pas parce qu'il ya des intervalles
pendant que le suprême qui s'appelle
dubai bon que moins de koné le dubaï
c'est une méthode qui est aussi
doublement dépendante des datations
puisqu'elle dépend donc quand on est sur
notre site
qu'on voit certaines a certes un pattern
d'aversion du champ électromagnétique
d'inversion de champs magnétiques ont
donc déjà on est dépendant d'une
datation pour savoir à quel moment
grosso modo on est dans dans le temps
mais après faut arriver à comparer ça
donc une à une
un pattern de base le pattern de seine
la séquence d'inversion des champs
électromagnétiques de de référence qui a
elle-même été mesuré si je ne me trompe
dans l'océan atlantique et qui dépend là
aussi de datation oui alors là pour un
coup on est vraiment dans ce que tout à
l'heure jamais entendu le mot événement
quand on parlait des cycles astronomie
du climat donc c'est pas des événements
mais les cycles par contre là on est
dans les vêtements par exemple il ya un
événement qui s'appelle réunion alors en
fait y en a deux enfin pour certains il
y en a deux pour d'autres n'auraient
qu'un mais bon visiblement il y en
aurait 2 qui est avec 2,2 points 14
millions d'années et de lui ça c'est ça
vient de la réunion c'est à dire qu'il
faut aller sur l'île de la réunion
enfin c'est un événement qui a été
décrit sur sur l'île de la réunion qui a
donné le nom est pas une c'est pas
hasard puisque là-bas il ya des basaltes
et du coup on a pu donner des dates
assez exactement
voilà son robuste quoi alors le produit
par exemple dans le bassin du turkana
il ya des travaux
parce que dans la science il ya des
conflits scientifique alors il ya des
travaux qui ont été faits qui ont montré
que cet événement existe je pense par
exemple comment dire un intervalle
géologique qu'on appelle dans un membre
géologie qui s'appelle cailloux par un
palais omar mané titien et puis il y en
a eu un autre d'une autre équipe qui a
travaillé sur un forage dans la même
région qui lui considère qu'il n'est pas
présent dans le bassin du turkana
c'est des conflits de chapelles
j'imagine que c'est dû aussi à la nature
elle-même des données c'est à dire qu'il
ya que deux chances soit c'est dans un
sens soit c'est dans l'autre donc il ya
des patterns ya des patterns qui doit
forcément se ressembler oui similaires
comme si on n'avait pas de coin de
passionnés pas la chronologie des
volcaniques
il faudrait vraiment avoir une séquence
très longue ce qui est possible dans le
bassin du turkana mais avoir une circus
une séquence très continue je veux dire
sur plus d'un million d'années c'est
quand même très long déjà et la
championne et sur le terrain ça me
rappelle certains sites que sur lesquels
j'ai des collègues qui ont travaillé qui
ont ils ont essayé de date est justement
au paléomagnétisme et alors il s'était
retrouvé dans la situation très
embêtante où il avait qu'une seule
inversion du champ magnétique et là on
peut pas faire grand chose est
absolument n'importe quoi c'est savoir
si on n'a pas la chance si voilà si on
est dans un intervalle de temps par
exemple voilà on dans le match ou yamaha
il se passe entre voilà il se passe plus
de 500 mille ans il n'y a pas de voie
rien donc la personne qui va les
chantiers n'est va passer beaucoup de
temps et n'aura pas des résultats
probants et ça semble important de
préciser que d'une ces changements sont
géologiquement très rapide c'est à dire
qu'on n'a jamais vus jeu en fer pourrait
confirmer mais je pense pas qu'on ait
jamais vu de 2000 champs magnétiques fin
de 2000 ration de champs magnétiques
on jamais entendu parler de ça voilà je
en tout cas un moment où des deux champs
magnétiques serait à l'équateur en train
de migrer
je ne vois pas que ça existe et on
et puis ça a pas l'air d'avoir des faits
particuliers sur la biosphère ou la
géosphère ou quoi que ce soit c'est à
dire que c'est jamais accompagné
d'événements catastrophiques du point de
vue géologique ou d'extinction du point
de vue biologique qods est et est ce
qu'on a et je crois pas qu'on ait une
idée très précise de comment ça se
produit d'ailleurs non je sais qu'on va
certainement nous poser la question dans
les commentaires mais ça c'est vraiment
un truc de géophysiciens quoi d'accord
alors on peut on peut finir avec les
méthodes stratigraphique avec la
biostratigraphie alors là je crois que
je peux prendre la parole sur cette
méthode là parce que c'est un truc que
je pratique assez souvent
donc là biostratigraphie finalement
c'est quelque chose de tout simple le
l'idée de base c'est l'évolution existe
donc l'évolution des espèces existent
donc si on prend deux intervalles de
temps différent on va forcément y voir
une faune et une flore différente parce
que c'est faux nez c'est flores aurait
évolué et puis à partir de là on peut on
peut facilement s'imaginer que en
fonction des faunes et des fleurs qu'on
va trouver on va tout simplement avoir
affaire à des âges différents
après ce qu'il ya de bien c'est que la
fin ce qu'il ya de bien c'est pas
forcément bien étant donné qu'on est en
train d'en vivre une mais la vie est
rythmée d'extinction plus ou moins
massive
certains disent qu'on est déjà dans la
6ème grosse mme groos extinction de
masse mais il n'ya pas que les
extinctions de masse il ya aussi des
extinctions mineures et il semblerait
que l'évolution de la vie soit ponctué
de d'extinction mineurs de telle sorte
qu'on a pu définir des étages donc on a
pu définir les grands les grands airs et
ses grands airs on a pu les découper en
période d'essai période on a pu les et
coupez en étages plus petits ainsi de
suite justement en se basant sur les
faune et la flore de ces étages qui sont
à chaque fois séparés par des
extinctions mineurs quand on te dit avec
cinq extinctions mineurs ça peut être
juste trois quatre espèces qui
s'éteignent mais c'est trois quatre
espèces qu'on va retrouver dans un
intervalle de temps
uniquement cet intervalle de temps là et
donc grâce à ça on définit ce qu'on
appelle des biozone c'est à dire qu'il
ya une zone biologique dans laquelle on
ne trouve qui dans laquelle on va
trouver un certain nombre d'espèces
parmi lesquels des espèces qui vont
correspondre cassette biozone après il
ya d'autres on peut utiliser d'autres
espèces comme des recoupements d'espèces
etc
mais c'est plus compliqué là on va
parler au plus simple ce qu'on appelle
les biozone totale c'est-à-dire une
espèce qu'on retrouve du début à la fin
d'une biozone donc voilà ça c'est ça
c'est le principe de la biozone nation
c'est à dire que les espèces évoluent de
temps en temps il ya des extinctions et
du coup on va avoir des espèces limitée
dans le temps et cette limitation dans
le temps qu'on va exploiter pour pouvoir
corps et les différentes roches
même si ces roches ne ressemblent pas
même si elles sont sur différents
continents si on trouve la même espèce
dedans on peut déclarer sans trop se
tromper que ces roches sont du même âge
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on utilise
beaucoup ici dans le karoo c'est même
quasiment exclusivement ça qu'on utilise
pour corréler les différentes parties du
bassin du caroux le carrosse est plus
grand que la france donc c'est un énorme
bassin
et pour arriver à corréler toutes les
parties ça a été assez compliqué parce
que le bassin est beaucoup plus épais au
sud ouest
je suis beaucoup plus apaisé au
sud-ouest au nord-est
donc il ya des grosses lacunes
sédimentaires au nord-est qu'on a du mal
à cibler et c'est grâce à la biozone
nation on a réussi à se repérer dans ce
bassin sinon le géologiquement c'est
toujours la même chose qui se passe
c'est à dire en alternance marno
gréseuses pendant 100 millions d'années
et c'est donc c'est tout se ressemble
absolument tout vous voyagez du nord fin
du nord-est au sud-ouest tout se
ressemble
mais c'est grâce à ces justement ces
fossiles qu'on va arriver à déterminer à
quelle dans quelle partie du bassin au
lait donc on a on a plusieurs biozone
qui sont basés sur les était rapide donc
les les prémat malien mes ancêtres des
mammifères
et donc est ce qui ce qui est
intéressant avec cette bio zonation
c'est que non seulement on peut
l'appliquer au niveau du bassin mais en
plus on s'est rendu compte qu'on pouvait
l'appliquer par delà le bassin c'est à
dire dans d'autres terrains qui datent
du permien trias donc oui peut-être dû
commencer par ça il s'agit d'un bassin
qui est essentiellement permet un terme
au trias avec un petit peu du jurassique
à la fin donc entre 265 et 200 millions
d'années en gros donc ça on l'a 65
millions d'années après en dessous de ça
on peut d on a encore des des sédiments
mais il ya moins de fossile de dent donc
on va dire qu'on va pas les compter mais
normalement le bassin entier couvre 100
millions d'années mais on va utiliser
que les 60 millions d'années qui sont
très riches en fossiles
déjà il ya du boulot et donc on a
remarqué donc cette séquence de
succession de biozone qui ce qui a lieu
dans ce bassin on la retrouve dans
d'autres endroits où il ya des terrains
du permien et du trias donc on y
retrouve notamment en afrique en
tanzanie par exemple on la retrouve au
zimbabwe et on la retrouve au botswana
et on la retrouve aussi en amérique du
sud on la retrouve aussi en russie on la
retrouve en chine alors très récemment
en chine et on l'a même utiliser ça en
france parce qu on a une une dalle à
empreintes de pas à la lieue de près de
lodève donc dans le sud de la france
et cette dalle à empreintes de pas en
fonction des taxons qui ont fait enfin
des espèces qui ont fait ces empreintes
ce qu'on a réussi plus ou moins à
déterminer on a réussi à dater cette
dalle en se basant justement sur le
registre fossile africains donc alors
qu'il n'y a pas de date du tout ou
presque dans le bassin de lodève
donc voilà on utilise c'est donc en
afrique du sud en finale on a sept
encore une fois c'est un code-barres on
reprend l'image du code barre mais c'est
un code-barres biologique c'est à dire
qu'on a au lieu d'avoir des successions
d'inversion de champs magnétiques là on
a des successions de faune on sait dans
quel ordre se succèdent et on arrive du
coup à corréler ça avec d'autres bassa
et viana ce bien à ça vient s'ajouter à
sa lé datation absolue puisque on a
aussi quelques tuf volcanique intercalé
ils sont très sains
ils sont très rares donc on n'est pas en
contrat
on n'a pas encore des âges très très
très contraint et c'est un effort qui
est très récent qui à peine 30 ans ici
donc jusqu'à ya trente ans c'était
purement de la biostratigraphie mais
maintenant on a aussi des tubes
volcaniques qui sont venues s'intercaler
là dedans et qui permettent de dire
juste de donner à ces biozone des âges
et là où c'est bien c'est que maintenant
qu'on a réussi à corréler toutes ces
parties du monde
il ya certaines parties du monde où ils
ont beaucoup de tuf volcanique à des
endroits où en afrique du sud on en a
pas donc maintenant on peut on peut
regrouper
donc maintenant on arrive à recouper
toutes ces informations et a créé une
série composite on va dire de succession
biozone intercalé de tubes qui
permettent de donner des âges
donc maintenant on a un outil qui est
assez puissant finalement et qui est
assez cohérent c'est aussi ça encore une
fois il faut regarder la cohérence de
l'outil c'est à dire qu'on va pas donner
n'importe quelle date n'importe quel
endroit aveuglément il faut voir si tout
ça ça raconte la même histoire si ça
raconte des histoires on a des dates par
exemple qui ne colle pas avec la
stratigraphie comme je le disais des
terrains qui sont censés être en dessous
des autres mais qui ont un âge très
jeune et du coup ça ça reste des grosse
énigme et encore une fois comme on dit
on utilise le zircon et le cirque en
italie il ya plein de raisons pour
laquelle ça pourrait ne pas fonctionner
donc on se dit que bon on garde ça on
garde cette idée là dans un coin en se
disant on sait qu'il ya certains
endroits du bassin qui donnent un âge
très jeune alors qu'ils sont censés être
plus vieux que les autres est ce que
c'est un phénomène géologique est ce que
c'est juste eu des erreurs de datation
répété par coïncidence est ce que bon
c'est un pool de données qui existent
qu'on conserve et on épuise au fur et à
mesure que le l'image de ce bassin de
l'évolution de ce bassin est cette
bouille la datation de cette bio à
nation se construit et bien on rajoute
les pièces du puzzle
comment gères à travers le monde le fait
que les espèces étaient pas forcément
les mêmes dans le sud de l'afrique et au
nord de
de l'asie alors c'est un problème qui
est assez limité au permien trias
puisqu'il y avait qu un seul continent
mais selon lui la une c'est un seul
continent le climat était partout pareil
niveau
non non il ya des variations climatiques
on arrive même à avoir une gradation des
faunes en fonction des latitudes des
paléo latitude pour le couple mais c'est
vrai que la faune et est quand même
relativement homogène c'est à dire qu'en
russie par exemple on trouve pas
exactement les mêmes espèces mais par
contre c'est définitivement les mêmes
familles qu'on retrouve cette par
exemple au permis à moyens on a une bio
zone qui correspond au permien moyens ce
qui est ce qui est vraiment pratique
mais en même temps le permis un moyen se
termine par une extinction de masse
tranche est donc là pour le coup de la
biozone nation est la même partout
vu que c'est la même extrême soixante
dix membres n'ont pas pu vivre
séparément de façon isolée quoi un petit
peu on dit ça c'est ça ballard
l'endémicité ça existe il ya des limites
quand même à la bio seau nation comme
j'ai dit des fois on trouve des hp
incohérents sur les datations absolue
après il ya aussi le fait qu'il faut
partir du principe que toutes les phones
sont synchrones ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas on a vu par exemple sur
la bio zonation de l'éocène en europe
que lacan fait les faunes d'europe à la
femme d eau saine ce qui leur arrive
c'est qu'elles se font remplacer petit à
petit par les faunes asiatique est donc
cette faune elle vient de l'est est
envahi petit à petit le continent
européen
donc la nouvelle biozone qui arrive de
l'est elle est plus jeune dans en europe
de l'est
oui ou non elle est plus vieille en
europe de l'est qu'en france ou en
espagne par exemple
tiens je saurais pas dire exactement
c'est à dire que l'europe à l'époque
c'était un système d'il donc faut
s'imaginer qu'ils ont sauté dit laure
nil en fait mais je sais plus exactement
ce que c'est le pas de temps pour être
tout à fait honnête mais en tout cas
voilà c'est des phénomènes quand même
qu'il faut dont il faut tenir compte
donc le on essaye d'en tenir compte le
mieux possible évidemment mais c'est
vrai que là par contre les datation
absolue sont cruciales pour arriver à se
rendre compte de ce genre d'attaqués
unis cité pour croiser faut croiser
c'est toujours le même sort il n'y a pas
une méthode magique de datation mais au
moins ça veut dire que dans un endroit
où il ya absolument 0 tu volcanique ou 0
zircon pour dater si on a un fossile et
pour peu que ces fossiles sont un bon
marqueur stratigraphique évidemment mais
si on a un fossile on peut arriver quand
même à avoir une idée assez précise faut
savoir que la sur l'afrique en afrique
du sud notamment autour de la limite
permise trias parce que c'est là qu'il
ya eu le plus de travail en afrique du
sud on a un pas de temps au niveau de la
biostratigraphie de seulement 25 mille
ans donc on est quand même on est quand
même sur une précision bien millions
d'années voilà ça il n'y a pas de quoi
rougir et un autre truc sur la
biostratigraphie je vais terminer par ça
c'est là le principe d'évolution aussi
la face c'est encore basée sur le
principe d'évolution mais c'est vraiment
le principe des tendances évolutives à
savoir que par exemple si on prend les
humains mais les humains sont de très
mauvais marqueur stratigraphique on
utilise les marqueurs stratigraphique
pour dater les humains mais si on prend
l'évolution humaine on s'attend à
trouver les espèces à petit cerveau
avant les espèces à gros cerveau et du
coup ça veut dire que si on trouve une
espèce à petit cerveau on est sur un
baron ça donne une idée de l'âge du
fossile déjà de base ce qui demain ce
qui ne marche plus depuis qu'on a
découvert au monal eddy homo
floresiensis d'ailleurs mais c'est juste
pour qu'on comprenne le principe quoi
donc
et ça on a pu le faire alors pas avec
les humains puisque comme j'ai dit c'est
des très mauvais marqueur stratigraphie
qui sont ils sont pas assez nombreux on
ne retrouve pas assez par quoi tu es un
truc qu'on retrouve beaucoup c'est les
rongeurs ça les rongeurs on en retrouve
des pelletées on sait plus quoi en faire
heureusement qu'ils sont pas gros parce
que en saurez plus où les mettre en
force et les rongeurs c'est très très
utile pour la biostratigraphie de déjà
parce qu'ils se reproduisent très vite
ils font beaucoup de faux cils et ils
font ils évoluent très vite aussi de ce
fait du fait qu'ils se reproduisent très
vite
est ce qu'on a ce qu'on a beaucoup
utilisé en france notamment dans le
quercy c'est la tendance évolutive qu'on
les rougeurs de l'éocène et de ligues
hossein à avoir leur dans les dents de
plus en plus hautes
c'est à dire que à l'eocène le climat
est plutôt tropicale à tendance humide
donc les rongeurs se nourrit
essentiellement de deux substances
tendre des feuilles et des fruits et
plus on avance vers l'oligocène plus le
climat ça édifie plus les rongeurs vont
s'adapter aux plaies ouvertes et
notamment à la consommation de graminées
et avec ça arrive le problème d'arrivée
à consommer des graminées parce que les
graminées sont pleines de silice elles
ont des phyto lite qui usent les danses
un système de défenses naturelles contre
les herbivores et du coup les rongeurs
s'adaptant à la silice en fait vont
avoir des temps de plus en plus haute
parce que plus on a les dents haute et
plus on peut s'offrir le luxe de perdre
des morceaux voilà exactement donc et on
voit cette tendance évolutive et donc à
partir du moment où on a réussi à
reconstituer cette tendance évolutive et
bah il suffit de trouver de mesurer la
hauteur d'une banque de rongeurs qu'on
retrouve pour savoir où on est en fait
dans la stratigraphie donc ça s'il ya
quand même des gros présupposé c'est à
dire qu'il faut des faut avoir déjà
documenté le changement climatique avoir
réussi à dater ce changement climatique
y superposer l'évolution des rongeurs
que cette évolution des rougeurs ne
suive qu'une seule tendance
contrairement à l'évolution des yeux du
cerveau des humains que dont j'avais
parlé tout à l'heure qui qui a plein de
contre exemple faut que cette tendance
soit absolue et une fois qu'on a fait
tout ça alors les rongeurs devienne un
outil biostratigraphie qu'utile mais ça
mais ça a fait ses preuves et grâce à ça
on a réussi à corréler les grottes de
systèmes des grottes de du quercy qui
sont des grottes qui ont quand même
entre 30 et 40 millions d'années
donc c est grâce à ça on a réussi à
combler toutes ces grottes et se rendre
compte qu'elle n'avait pas toutes le
même âge et se rendre compte que
certaines parties étaient mélangés et
qu'il y avait des remaniements etc bref
ça va vraiment donner une image très
précise de ce qui s'est passé dans le
quercy alors même que ces grottes le
contenu de ces grottes ne peut pas être
datés directement mais grâce à des tubes
volcaniques qui aurait pu être datés
dans des bassins dans tes vrais bassin
sédimentaire pas dans des bassins
karstique
enfin je sais pas comment on dit pour
des bassins qu'un stick des assemblages
karstique quoi
dans des vrais bassins sédimentaires qui
ont accueilli des vrais tubes volcanique
on a pu voir cette même succession les
dater du coup corrélés tout ça ensemble
c'était là biostratigraphie donc encore
une fois c'est pas une méthode de
datation absolue ça on a besoin de deux
dates absolue pour pouvoir donner un âge
mais ça donne une idée assez précise
encore faut-il arriver à identifier les
bons fossiles voilà donc on passe à la
dernière partie et cette dernière partie
donc céder c'est aussi la méthode ce
sont aussi des méthodes de datation
relative cette fois fondée sur des
phénomènes cycliques saisonnier donc
encore une fois on va se tourner vers
vous aviez alors maintenant on parle de
classe et les barbes et la dendre ou
alors du coup ce sont des méthodes
alors c'est moi parce que c'est quelque
part ces données méthode absolue puisque
on s'en est servi pour calibrer le
radiocarbone est ce que c'est la méthode
relative à abbas à ses marques
intéressantes c'est vrai que ça donne un
âge savage l'anarchie alors qu'est-ce
que je commence par les vagues en fait
pour les bars et un mot un peu barbare
on aurait pu appeler ça plutôt
sédimentation annuellement la ministre a
été plus simple et plus long alors il ya
très peu d'environnement qui se prête à
la formation de va donc une var est
défini par un couplet ou un doublé de de
deux couches sédimentaires fine on parle
pas de sédimentation qui font par mois
20 cm c'est très fin parce que c'est
dans des environnements la sédimentation
lente continue donc forcément plus tôt
des environnements de type lacustre on
en trouve donc pratiquement partout sur
les continents alors c'est pas dans tous
les lacs
j'y reviendrai après et on en trouve
aussi mais bon c'est plus rare quand
même dans les milieux marins mais ça
existe j'évoquais tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs de façon un peu anticipé le
bassin du cariacou mais on ya le mot
bassins versants cargo voilà c'est
plutôt des environnements clos on va
dire les meilleurs varde
d'ailleurs si elle existe vraiment parce
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de débats là dessus
vont être dans des environnements clos
par exemple je pense à des bassins de
cratères bassin par exemple en afrique
de l'ouest le bassin le lac de bozouls
wii qui est un lac de cratère qui a une
séquence qui je sais plus si l approche
le million d'années mais enfin il ya des
vars d'essai libre parce que là on va
avoir un cratère lac de cratère un
milieu fermé
une fenêtre ouverte sur le climat sur
les cycles courts et longs donc par
exemple la cour un puisqu'il faut le cdh
mentation annuel donc la différence
entre je ne sais pas moi la période des
pluies et puis la période sèche ou alors
l'été et l'hiver
et puis donc un bassin fermé donc il va
accueillir une la mine par exemple
organique et puis une autre qui est
biologique et et ça il faut qu'il y ait
une continuité au cours du temps vaut
mieux avoir un bassin plus tôt clos
voilà pour éviter toute perturbation
toute intrusion
je pense alors il ya beaucoup de débats
sur les vars savoir si on a vraiment d
une année d'une sédimentation annuel
c'est ça la vraie question en fait parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de sédimentation
laminé qui ont l'air d'être laminés
annuellement mais est-ce qu'elles sont
laminés annuellement surviennent pas
moins 60 ans 200 à 300 ans milan faut
déjà prouvé parce que peut-être tout le
monde est pas familier avec le terme de
la mine est donc les var ce serait si on
est dans un environnement de dépôt très
très calme
oui on veut voir ce qu'on veut voir dans
des var mme c une pulsation en fête
annuelle de sédimentation de la personne
petite couche très fine voilà voilà
alors souvent il ya eu des gens qui ont
clamé on va dire qu'ils avaient des
sédimentation annuellement laminé mais
il faut le prouver que c'est
annuellement laminé alors il ya tout un
tas de méthodes pour prouver ou vérifier
plutôt que c'est laminé et annuellement
je pense notamment à l'or mois les les
plus beaux lacs
alors j'ai vu plusieurs là que j'aille
forêt pour plusieurs la que voilà dans
plus d'endroits du monde l'est vraiment
les vrais la qv harvick
ma connaissance qui prêtent pas à au
doute ce sont les lacs qui sont
périodiquement en glace est par exemple
je pense oh là que dans le très proche
du cercle polaire où chaque année depuis
des centaines d'années il y à de la
glace qui va recouvrir le lac pendant
six mois dans l'année
là il va y avoir une la mine qui va se
former qui va être plutôt dans un milieu
où il ya absence d'oxygène plutôt
organique donc des montagnes a pas de
vie quand la halle à l'épaisseur de
glace qui peut faire un maître va se
réduire et à prochain printemps ça va
avoir un effet de décupler
donc il va y avoir les uv qui vont
passer à travers la glace qui va se
devenir de plus en plus fine et en
dessous de ça donc il va y avoir un
milieu sur une lame d'eau qui va être
chauffée avec avec des conditions
optimales pour développer parmi les des
organismes rappellent les diatomées des
petits d'opale de silice et donc ces
organismes vont proliférer
alors on va pas la voir à ce moment là
dans la sédimentation c'est au moment où
le système a rebasculé à l'hiver où la
glace va reprendre le dessus et là du
coup tous ces organismes vont mourir est
bon se précipiter au fond du lac
alors j'en viens par exemple tout à
l'heure j'ai cité le baïkal il n'y a pas
de sédimentation de le lac baïkal parce
que c'est le lac le plus profond du
monde il faut des conditions optimales
également de profondeur pour que le
transfert des sédiments soit rapide au
niveau annuel c'est à dire qu'il faut
pas que il faut pas que le lac mead six
mois à ce que la particule descendent au
fond du lac pour s'alimenter
alors il avait été calculé que par
exemple pour qu'une particule dans le
lac baïkal qui arrive avec un cours
d'eau descendent au fond du lac
il faut plusieurs années alors on a
évoqué le taux à sept ans voire dix ans
donc par exemple et là que proche du
cercle polaire ils sont il faut qu'ils
aient quand même certaine profondeur
passant de 30 mètres ça c'est pas mal
parce qu'il va y avoir une lame d'eau
qui va donc se former et si par exemple
le vent par exemple aussi peut être
brassée l'eau et augmenter l'épaisseur
de la lame d'eau où il va y avoir de la
vie
et si par exemple à une période de
l'année il ya plus aimant et bien
l'épaisseur de la
oui à la vie pas disparaître et donc
tous les horizons vont mourir et donc il
faut qu'ils soient précipitées
rapidement au fond du lac pour que cette
lame il existe alors il ya eu beaucoup
de doutes j'ai beaucoup de travaux sur
les var 20 ans dans les lacs l'accusant
juin sujet évoqué twitter qui est même
eu des barques ont été utilisés pour
calibrer le sécateur c'est les travaux
lire carré d'as en comparant ces 14 le
radiocarbone les clébards mais moi je
connais par exemple les travaux de marie
mme berg qui a foré pendant trente ans
le même lac en faisant un trou sur la
glace et on a alors récolté donc ces
carottes je les fais moi-même avec lui
et donc quand on lui disait est ce que
votre là vous êtes sûr qu'il est
annuellement la ville et il y montrait
la collection de qu'il avait su
accumuler sur 30 ans où on pouvait tout
simplement comparé sur 30 ans et voir
qui allait bien 30 couplet de l'ami
[Musique]
compte les vab manuellement corps alors
après la la je pense que là par rapport
à tout ce que chante à nous expliquer
comme méthodes physiques parfois
extrêmement complexe quand on n'est pas
un adepte là c'est quand même très
simple le problème c'est qu'il faut
avoir accès au comptage alors par
exemple quand on est en d'autres
méthodes de comptage pendant que la
droguerie d'entre eux chronologie pardon
viendra après il faut avoir une section
c'est à dire qu'il faut polir où il faut
couper en fait le sédiment ça c'est
quand même très compliqué il faut donc
récolté une carotte au fond du lac donc
ça c'est compliqué il faut pas déformer
les le sédiment il faut voila voila
imprégnée de résine
alors souvent faux voit la voirie les
techniques de micro photographie au
championnat mais je connais des exemples
par exemple d'un delacauchy lit ou quand
le carottage a été fait on ouvre la
carotte en deux on ne voit absolument
pas de la mine et après imprégnation
avec des polymères qui permettent de
polir du coup une surface argileuse
gorgée d'eau donc il faut l'enlever
l'eau sans modifier comme à dire si on
prend de l'argile et qu'on l'a fait
sécher tout simplement on va se
retrouver avec un tout petit blog donc
il faut des techniques très complexes de
remplacement de l'eau sans modifier le
volume par des polymères pour pouvoir
après polir l'argile comme une roche il
dont j'avais peut-être dire une bêtise
mais
est-ce que je lai la carotte ça
marcherait pas alors ça peut marcher
mais il faut des techniques de gel très
particulier parce que le gel fait des
cracks des craquelures et peut détruire
un échantillon surtout quand il est
gorgé d'eau avec un des toners en eau
très forte
donc c'est louis il va y avoir un oui il
faut des techniques de gel j'ai oublié
le les termes techniques pour ça il faut
des gels oui enfin c'est le fruit ce
doyen en anglais mais il faut pas comme
à l'azoté liquide quoi un truc qui gèle
instantanément à ce transfert de
cristaux quoi voilà sans faire de plus
tôt parce que plus le temps pour le
jeune va être long plus écrite au bout
et très gros tout ça et ça va détruire
l'échantillon est pas une carotte de
forage
techniquement c'est quasiment c'est
quasiment irréalisable donc fait ça il
faut des techniques qui sont
reproductibles
ce va se poser aussi donc d'abord le
problème de prouver qu'on a ensuite
d'aider varda nu alors ça se les
meilleurs scientifiques qui ont
travaillé sur les barres ils ont des
pièges assez de ce qu'on appelle dpja
sédiments qu'ils ont posés notamment le
leem arenberg au fond du lac alors je
rigole parce que quand je pense à ces
peja sédiments moi ça me fait penser à
des grosses tolède qu'on envoie au fond
du lac et qu'on va récolter chaque année
ou à des moments précis de l'année donc
on va remonter ces pièges à sédiments
pour voir ce qui se passe au bout de six
mois qu'est ce qu'on a et donc là on va
faire ça sur plusieurs années donc c'est
long c'est coûteux en temps et donc ses
pièges et à sédiments vous permettre de
voir le lien qu'il ya entre la
sédimentation et les saisons ça c est un
exemple il ya d'autres choses aussi
d'autres méthodes je peux aura pas tous
les aborder ça serait trop long mais par
exemple on n'a pas parlé tout à l'heure
une méthode qui s'appelle le césium où
on va travailler sur une carotte d'ahmed
par exemple et on va voir si on retrouve
le les pics de césium qui sont liés à
tchernobyl
donc le 1986 et il ya un autre pic c'est
les essais nucléaires et donc quand on
fait une ciné mentation dans un lac on
va déjà vérifié ça on va partir du haut
et on va donc voir s'il ya des la mine
s'il y en a on va donc les comptes et
faire des comptages tout bête de
couplets et ensuite si on a les pics de
césium on va regarder si c'est cohérent
si c'est pas cohérent c'est même c'est
pas la peine de continuer et puis aussi
on va avoir des points de contrôle avec
le radiocarbone c'est un peu bizarre
parce que tout à l'heure j'ai dit on
utilise les var pour calibrer le
radiocarbone mais ça ça a été des
travaux très très lourd avec des
multiplications des échantillons de
natation ms va là il faut des
échantillons pour les varois pour le
coup des bombes du coup ce conte des
bombes nucléaires ce qu'on fait c'est
donc on compte les couplets de vars mais
est en fait en fonction d'un conte
départ on part de l'année zéro donc si
on remonte le temps 1986 on doit trouver
un pic de césium et on remonte le temps
comme on connaît chaque date en fait de
chaque essai nucléaire c'est ça après
fois dans la vision du monde où ça vous
a marqué alors je suis pas sûr que pas
un tchernobyl je sais qu'il ya eu des
choses au chili par exemple dans
l'hémisphère sud qui ont marché juge je
crois que oui je saïs mémoire le
tchernobyl on le voit mais par exemple
les autres essais nucléaires il ya un
autre prix vers les années 50-60 là il
n'était pas vu je suis d'accord d'accord
et du coup c'est var mais quand on
arrive une fois une fois qu'on a vérifié
que ces vagues sont annuelles qu'on peut
qu'on l'a démontré là on a un outil
extrêmement puissant
howie en natation puissant encore
faut-il que le lac
vraiment il faut des supers lac ce que
j'ai dit il faut qu'ils aient déjà il
faut par exemple dans les lacs de
l'amérique du sud en amérique du sud
il faut être par exemple dans la zone
des oies stérilise les vents d'ouest qui
vont chaque année rythmée la colonne
d'eau la retourner absence de retourne
donc il ya tous les nutriments qui vont
arriver
ça va permettre de nourrir une flore
faune enfin les diatomées explosion en
anglais beginning enfin là et puis après
mort il ya ces super là qu'il faut aussi
des candidats profondeur comme je les
dis le lan baca qui est un super là
comme l'huile à un kilomètre 7 de
colonne d'eau pas possible d'avoir une
sédimentation rapide
et donc il faudrait donc bien placé au
niveau climatique avoir un fort signal
climatique annuel et il faut avoir les
bonnes conditions profondeur et tout est
ensuite il faut aussi donc ça fait
beaucoup d'eux et ça fait beaucoup de
lacs mais c'était pareil pour les
attentions physique il faut aussi par
exemple quand on fait un carottage pas
avoir un lac par exemple dans la zone
chilienne fin dans la zone à la veille
du sud il ya beaucoup de vocalys mhz et
2 et de tecktonik d'activité tectoniques
qui fait qu' on a ce qu'on ait des
éléments des sédiments qui ont été
perturbés par des tremblements de terre
par exemple je pense à la queue donc en
chili qui a un nom un peu barbare
pourriez houllier qui malheureusement
enfin qui heureusement a été barré mais
qui malheureusement est près de
l'épicentre du plus gros tremblement de
terre enregistré le promoteur de
valdivia qui et c'est leur corps ou
encore man donc je sais plus quel est l
échelle ces 8e 8
saleh tweet points alors je dis
peut-être une mission à temps tout cas
c'est le recordman et donc pas de chance
là il ya eu tout d'un coup un intervalle
dans la sédimentation qui date de 1960
qui est complètement perturbé donc du
coup on arrête le comptage alors après
on peut reprendre le comptage en dessous
de la ce qu'on appelle une turbidité
l'événement tu perturbé mais le problème
c'est que s'il ya eu une perturbation de
la sédimentation ya de fortes chances
qu'il y ait un paquet de vars précédents
qui étaient enlevés dont on sait combien
quand on sait pas combien
donc il faut voilà le mieux c'est
d'avoir des supers là qui sont très
rares et qui ont une sédimentation moi
je pense au lac de cratère où voilà là
c'est une fenêtre rythmée par un climat
deux hommes par exemple type tropical et
puis donc là moi je pense au labo ou twi
des choses comme ça où il ya un million
d'années
de sédimentation peut-être pas tout
garder mais voilà après ça va offrir un
chronologie qui peut être flottante
aussi c'est à dire que si on a un
intervalle dans le temps qui est varié
sur je ne sais pas moins 15 mètres
c'est quand même précieux donc là de
nouveau il va falloir travailler avec
d'autres dates heures pour combler les
exploiter ce enregistrement climatique
parce que en paléoclimatologie c'est un
outil très fort le livre puisqu'il ya un
fort lien entre alimentation âge et
climat donc ça va servir ça va servir au
niveau des microfossiles qu'on voit à
l'intérieur en fait dans les barbes donc
les diatomées des choses comme ça où les
algues voilà ce que je voulais dire
c'est que le premier maître est
décompacté celle que sédiments n'est pas
compact et avec la colonne d'eau et le
poids des sédiments puisse on va aller
en profondeur dans une carotte qui fait
juste par 80 mètres il rien un
intervalle qui va être dangereux où il
faut pas travailler sur les épaisseurs
parce qu'il ya des var quand j'ai dit il
ya un couplet mais en fonction du climat
annuel et au cours du temps le climat a
changé soit il va être un peu plus harry
soit plus de mise donc ça ça va un
impact sur la quantité de sédiments
accumulés mais sauf qu'il ya un moment
donné donc ça on peut le faire sur le
premier maître qui est décompacté
souvent c'est le premier m mais après il
faut attendre il faut aller en
profondeur ou de la compaction on allait
agir de façon il ya une compassion mais
elle agit surtout la colonne
sédimentaires et donc même si on a plus
l'épaisseur réelle de la découpe l'est
on peut s'en servir quand même parce
qu'on voit qu'il ya des ce fameux code
barre a une signification
donc parce que par exemple s'il ya une
la mine qui fait c'est pas moi 1,5
millimètre de diatomées vert je sais pas
moi quinze mille ans et puis que si on
va dix mille ans plus tard et que toute
la série les la mine de diatomées sont
beaucoup plus petites ou ou qu'elle joue
beaucoup plus vite
ça veut dire qu'il ya voilà le climat et
il est plus comme il ya ici que sont
différents c'est un outil très fort
quand même pour la paléoclimatologie
très fort mais du coup assez limité on
va dire au niveau de l'applicabilité
c'est à dire comme comme vous disiez il
faut vraiment des lacs avec aaron
avec un enregistrement exceptionnel quoi
oui il faut des lacs avait s'est pas
trompé la toule hélas pas parce qu'on a
alarcon à ça par exemple le bassin du
turkana
il y en a pas de barre alors que c'est
un lac
actuellement il fait entre 30 mètres en
moins il ya une moyenne de 30 mètres et
il va jusqu'à 100 m il ya peut-être des
endroits dans le bassin où il ya
peut-être des var mais trente mètres
j'ai dit 30 m c'est bien ça dépend parce
que là est le problème du rift c'est
qu'il ya un vent très fort qui s'appelle
le turkana jet c'est un vent très fort
donc ça ça va brasser l'eau sur une
profondeur plus importante donc ça
risque d'atteindre ça ça va atteindre si
par exemple la colonne d'eau et brassées
sur toute sa hauteur
ça va perturber chaque fois la
sédimentation donc on va pas permettre
la préservation du couple est même si
par exemple à l'origine il y avait une
pulsation annuelles d'enseignement
c'est dommage parce que leurs cadets
c'est un endroit on en aurait bien
besoin
mais la naissance on n'a pas d'accord et
la dernière méthode du coup c'est la
d'andreu chronologie voici un peu comme
le comme le principe de comptage en fait
très simple
en fait il ya un fort lien entre la
formation des desserts n'da de décès
chaque année en fait l'arbre va faire
une serbe est il le stress va être
différent en fonction de chaque année si
les hivers sont rudes il est interactif
à l humidité
donc on va avoir un espèce de
code-barres sur les épaisseurs de des
desserts n'est en fait sur les
rythmiques et des desserts n'est en fait
en faisant des collections dans les
années 80 je me souviens il était en
pleine constitution des collections des
dons qu'ils étaient très demandeurs
justement dans les milieux
archéologiques pour avoir des troncs
d'arbres souvent des chaînes pendant
qu'elle ait trouvé par exemple dans les
gravières ou en milieux archéologiques
par exemple je pense à a
comment dire des coffrages de q2 puis
roma où on peut aussi faire de la dendre
haut dans les charpentes d'église du
moyen-âge en faisant juste un petit
problème en renfort avec un forage et
donc toutes ses collections se sont dit
on n'a pas obligé de couper à chaque
fois oui on époque et c'est souvent
voilà pendant les structures m'a juste
fait un petit carottages ou un arbre
encore vivants on peut le faire aussi
mais si on a des troncs fausse pas
facile mais si on a des trombes
on va plutôt faire une section et puis
donc on va simplement mesurer avec des
techniques d'imagerie donc ces photos de
cerner puis on va mesurer les un peu
comme les bars vont va mesurer les
épaisseurs de c1 on va avoir un espèce
de diagrammes comme ça avec des
variations et on va super pg est
différent
pourquoi la section la section des
arbres voilà voilà des chevauchements de
chaque section
c'était au début que c'était très
compliqué quand ils ont constitué les
collections parce qu'il était demandeur
pour certains un intervalle où il n'y
avait pas justement la jonction donc une
fois qu'on a toute cette histoire des
cernes d'arbres
c'est l'âge ionale ça dépend de l'espèce
de l'avant et c'est une fois qu'on a
cette collection et qu'on trouve un
morceau ou d'arbres voilà quelque part
dans une structure etc
regardez cet or est allé regarder quel
tronçon ça correspond pour pouvoir
donner l'âge parfois l'année presse est
très précis pas en europe par exemple
moi je connais bien les travaux sur les
chaînes parce que bon en europe à partir
du moment où il ya de reichshoffen le
réchauffement climatique actuel de dire
le réchauffement postglaciaire donc
après douze mille ans il ya eu beaucoup
de forêts de chênes en europe et c'est
vrai que les chaînes ont été beaucoup
utilisés par l'homme aussi on en trouve
aussi dans les gravières par exemple
dans la vallée du rhin et jose a donc
cédé arbres qui se prête bien à la
dendre oncologie je connais pas bien les
travaux je sais qu'il ya eu aussi des
travaux d'entre eux promologis pas en
amérique du sud qui ne sont pas sur des
chaînes mais
[Musique]
en fait l'âge du l'âge du dépôt du
fragment d'arbres ou l'âge de de la
poutre de charpente ou de quoi que ce
soit c'est ça correspond dernière cern
en fait de la d'oncle celle qui a été
formé juste avant que l'arbre soit
coupée c'est salage et du coup grâce à
ses séries donc ces superpositions de
redoutables mises bout-à-bout de c'est
ça on a une section type et il suffit de
compter du coup sur cette section type
combien de cernes
on a jusqu'à atteindre la dernière cern
de notre arbre qu'on a trouvée pour
donner l'âge
oui mais là pour un coup ça va être
vraiment les épaisseurs c'est à dire
qu'il ya vraiment un espèce de
diagrammes
voilà qui va superposés qui a la même
allure
ça va être tout à fait juste le mali
forcément parce que l'épaisse
l'épaisseur des cernes va permettre de
superposer c'est à dire que c'est mais
c'est un peu comme le paléomagnétisme
c'est à dire qu'on a pas d on a pas d
épaisseur de cernes rigoureusement les
mêmes chaque année à la donc c'est la
variation de ces épaisseurs qui va
permettre d'identifier de superposer c
voilà ça c'est là la cause différence
avec les vars par exemple les vars dans
un lac
ça ne marchera que dans un lac c'est à
dire qu'il faut partir du haut et puis
descendre sur jeu paramètres de
carottage ou là on va simplement content
là ça marche le comptage
mais par contre la chronologie d'andrew
chronologie l'on peut comparer des
arbres qui viennent de différentes
régions et si on peut les mettre bout à
bout on peut les mettre bout à bout
tant que ces temps que toutes ces
régions ont subi le même climat climat
je sèche les systèmes de l'est
calibration sont quand même relativement
régional donc yu na on n'a pas tout à
fait les mêmes courbes dans le sud de la
france et oui nos articles
pour les je pense aux justement dans les
travaux des valves sur les lacs
d'amérique du sud
évidemment on a comparé avec et des
résultats d'entreprises aux logiques de
la région d'abyei du sud ne pourrait pas
comparer avec un résultat dans gros qui
aimeraient d'europe et on arrive à
remonter jusqu'à quand avec ça parce que
vous parliez tout à l'heure ça a été
utilisé pour la calibration carbone 14
donc quand même ça a l'air d'être un
outil plus puissant et très est très
fiable
je sais j'ai dit mais là bah oui puisque
on n'a pas trouvé d'armes
enfin il ya des arbres plus anciens mais
ce que j ai assez c'est une méthode qui
est utilisée oui voilà c'est pour lolo
c'est vraiment pour le losc
on va dire ou es du dernier millénaire
quoi c'est vrai que le registre fossile
après tant que ça c'est des arbres qui
sont faux cils ou sub fossiles on va
dire c'est vrai que le registre fossile
des arbres pas déjà il fait pas l'objet
d'autant d'attention qu'ils le devraient
pour commencer puis c'est vrai qu'il ya
on a des gros patch en fait il ya des
endroits où on trouve des forêts
entières puis plus rien pendant des
millions d'années puis on va retrouver
des forêt pétrifiée entière c'est vrai
que c'est pas donc on pourrait dans
l'absolu on pourrait dans l'absolu
utiliser la dendrochronologie peuvent
ponctuellement mais on n'arriverait pas
à compter comme on fait à partir de zéro
comme regarder pendant la coupe de
référence pour pouvoir les recalés et
cette courte de référence à n'existe que
pour les dix derniers milliers d'années
quoi moi je connais pas oui moi ce
moment un outil qui est utilisé pour
tout l'eau saine quoi d'accord c'est
quand même impressionnant qui ce que ce
soit suffisamment fiable pour qu'on
puisse qu'aller corrigé là le carbone 14
là-dessus quoi à pisser intéressant
enfin le référentiel est intéressant
parce que du coup ils ont pu le dater au
carbone 14 directement donc là on s'est
vraiment engagé sur une synergie
inspectant oublie souvent dans l'est
dans nos études on viole à la il ya des
raisonnement circulaire qu'on fait des
hypothèses et puis en fait on se rend
compte
on a les résultats parce qu'on a fait la
bonne hypothèse bref donc là dans ce
système là son éclat et de l'autre mais
on ne peut pas parler vraiment de ces
problèmes c'est vrai qu'il faut faire
très attention raisonnement circulaire
tiens ça me je repense tout à l'heure
par exemple à la cyclo stratigraphie les
cycles astronomiques
ça m'a étonné qu'il ait pas la question
parce que par exemple si on part du
principe qu'on a des cycles qui dit que
les cycles sont qu'on a vues sont bien
ceux de cent mille quarante mille ou
20000 pas en plus je pense à ça parce
que bon nous on a eu un papier de
publier sur ben justement voilà et ça a
été un moment de l'hymne des questions
d'un de quelqu'un qui avait revu les
articles en disant voilà est en fait bon
là le fait est qu'on a beaucoup qu'on a
quand même des datations par ailleurs
d'argon à gong qui fait qu'on peut
contrôler pas tout à fait passé comme
moi tout à l'heure quand je parlais que
justement on avait notre bio donations
et puis que quand on avait une date qui
n'allait pas ce qui n'allait pas on la
mettait de côté on ne l'ignorent pas
mais en comme je dis on la met de côté
et elle rentre pas dans le schéma
narratif qui nous sert à dater nos
fossiles mais voilà c'est pareil on
utilise aussi différentes sources c'est
à dire qu'il n'ya pas que la biozone à
sion il ya aussi la stratigraphie elle
même c'est à dire que le principe de la
gravité a toujours fonctionné donc les
cours les couches d'en dessous ne
peuvent pas être plus jeunes que les
couches d'eau dessus donc on il ya aussi
le et puis bah on recoupe avec les
autres dates et on regroupe donc on a
des dates sur des zircons on a des dates
aussi ceux qui sont faites sur des tubes
donc je suppose que c'est sur le lagon
bien que ce soit bien que ce soit les
ait reconquis sont nettement dominant
talent qui est la méthode de datation
vêtements dominante parce qu'elle est
beaucoup moins cher et mais voilà donc
on a quand même tout s'est passé comme
les méthodes de datation vous utilisez
c'est la luminescence haussier elle a
ses faiblesses et peut-être des passages
qui sont circulaires mais encore une
fois c'est le recoupement de tous nous
ensemble et la cohérence interne en fait
c'est la cohérence interne de toutes ces
méthodes qui va qui va faire qu'on va
c'est qu'on va établir un consensus
autour d'une date en particulier pour
pour un fossile donné mais qu'on va
privilégier et et si jamais il ya des
conflits ben on va privilégier celles
qui
celle qui est le plus cohérent avec tout
avec d'autres méthodes
et si jamais il ya vraiment un 50/50
voilà on va on va pas prendre de
décision enfin je pense que enfin je
suppose qu'on fonctionne tout sa vie
d'après comme ça la multiplication des
données quoi aussi ça c'est pas j'ai pas
de polémique mais des fois les
archéologues ont tendance à choisir la
date qui correspond à l'hypothèse qui ça
mais ça finira toujours pas se voir en
fin du mois un jour quelqu'un va passer
derrière
pourquoi là avoue qu'on trouvera la
preuve que enfin en améliorant les
datations ne faisant plus en nous
faisant différemment que voilà pour
résoudre le problème
non on a le même problème avec la limite
permet à trias il ya un chercheur donc
les chercheurs sud africains ont
déterminé que la limite permise trias
était à 252 millions d'années ce qui la
rend coïncidente avec le la limite
permise trias dans le milieu marin parce
que dans en afrique du sud elle est en
milieu terrestre alors qu'en chine ils
l'ont en milieu marin donc pour nous
l'extinction des espèces qu'on voit en
afrique du sud et coïncidente avec
l'extinction des espèces qu'ils voient
en milieu marin en chine à la même
époque et il ya une équipe américaine
qui conteste cette date et qui a fait
ses propres datation les pour eux 252
pour eux 252 millions d'années donc là
l'extinction de masse
elle est à elle et je sais pas combien
de mètres au dessus de ce que nous on
appelle la limite permise trias sauf que
bah du coup il se passe rien la nive au
changement de biologique donc si la
limite permise trias il l extinction de
masse
elle est dans un endroit où il n'y a
aucune extinction
on a du mal on a du mal à privilégier
cette hypothèse voilà donc ont pris vie
pour l'instant au privilégient
l'hypothèse où les deux dit mid term
bien trias sont synchrones et voilà en
milieu terrestre et en milieu marin
parce que c'est là qu'on voit le
turnover d'espèces qui se produit qui
sait dans le futur ce qui va se passer
mais en tout cas c'est encore une fois
on reste dans le recoupement
d'informations les hypothèses
raisonnables et ses règles et quand une
hypothèse n'est pas raisonnable et pas
ça se voit voilà je pense du mois que
qu'elle sera critiqué et j'ose espérer
qu'elle sera critique ok bah je crois
qu'on a bien bien bien fait le tour du
sujet dans deux heures trente
voilà en une demi-heure plus deux heures
[Musique]
en tout cas je vous remercie beaucoup de
nous avoir accordé de votre temps parce
que ça fait vraiment très plaisir
d'avoir deux experts qui nous accordent
de leur temps pour nous expliquer des
choses qui s'est fini enfin qui ont tant
d'importance et qui sont pourtant si peu
couvertes dans les dires dans tout ce
qui est source d'information mainstream
donc merci beaucoup merci ça a été un
grand plaisir de vous accueillir avec
nous ça a été un grand plaisir de vous
avoir comme auditeur je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne
ciao d'avoir
[Musique]